day one of the much-anticipated
candidates tournament in Yekaterinburg
Russia a jewel on the chess calendar
eight of the top players in the world
began their campaign to decide a
challenger to world champion Magnus
Carlsen
shiny star Wang Hao pulled off a big
upset by defeating his Olympic teammate
ding Lauren but the game of the round
was yan upon that she's sterling play
against Dutchman an ish giri that now
places the russian in a two-way tie for
first it's the greatest show on earth as
the chess gladiators are back to do
battle round 2 of exciting action coming
up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from the Hyatt Regency in Yekaterinburg
this is round 2 of the 2020 candidates
to determine who is going to face the
world champion Magnus Carlsen later this
year it's a do-or-die tournament and
yesterday the players brought the fire
they sure did Alejandro Nesta I see with
you hello everyone and welcome to our
live coverage of the candidates twenty20
tournament it was an amazing amazing
first round two decisive games two draws
and in the decisive games the players
who lost previously had played in the
candidates and never lost a single game
so that was so shocking and those
players who lost it with white alejandro
it was an amazing first round if we get
any of that kind of action this is going
to be the tournament of tournaments
let's take a look at our standings
absolutely after just one round we have
two boat leaders leaders one Jana from
Yahtzee both wandered games with the
black pieces against onigiri and Bingley
Ren who are sitting at the bottom
meanwhile the draws between Fabio
Khurana and mvl and Alexandra Chris
Chuck and Carol Alex & Co put them with
half a point each right well it's only
been one round but it feels like they've
given us so much confidence let's take a
look at the format of the event double
round-robin because as I said one round
played 13 to go this is a 14 round event
very long by today's standards also a
long time control if you're a fan of
classical chest is your event 100
minutes from the first 40 moves 50
minutes for the next 20 that means that
I've moved 60 you get another 15 minutes
to finish your game and all throughout
you'll have a 30 second increment now
new rule for the candidates no draw
offers before blocks warriors move
none of those shenanigans half a million
euros in prize fund but let's be real
one true price and that is to
win the tournament and challenge Magnus
Carlsen for the crown that's what
everybody is gunning for lots of chess
to be played still they're gonna have a
schedule more or less of three games
played one rest day three games played
one rest day today's round two tomorrow
we'll have round three and the day after
you see that remark that'll be our first
rest day of the tournament and of course
with us
it's Grandmaster Maurice actually to
give us well some breaking news
apparently indeed breaking news
Alejandro yeah sir we have a big game of
foot one of the top two players of the
tournament favorite to win it off by
some of the favorite to win in Hall
ding Loren is now dead lost against
Maxime Vasily Gras his position is
horrible
look at this he's already down
materially dropped this pawn after this
moves c4 earlier in the position if I
can jump back to right here c-4 was
played he wasn't able to take on c4
because of Bishop to a4 skewering this
rook but the problem was he couldn't
even move the rook out of the way after
c4 because captures if you capture back
it doesn't matter Knight takes on e5 an
explosion in his position after captures
d6 the obvious discovery on the King the
fort coming
the bishop dropping this is just
horrible his position would have
collapsed completely instead he played a
knight of seven and just gave this pawn
away now down a full pawn after Bishop
to c4 King going to g6 and then this
aggressive g4 9h say Queen f3 Bishop to
d8 and now this is all all Maxime in
this position he's got a b4 break coming
up material this is just a bad position
for black can he survive he is in
trouble he lost yesterday and - who else
but his countryman I spoke earlier in
the open about his Olympic teammate but
actually it's only his countryman Wang
Hao who has not played on the Chinese
Olympic team in a while but he is
showing that he
Olympian of Olympians because he did
take a bite out of crime yesterday and
showing that yeah I might be ranked
seventh in this tournament but I'm here
to win he is the qualifier from the feed
a grand swiss of 2019 winning that event
he has jumped into the top ten in the
world right now
and he has knocked out another perennial
top-10 player a nice giri who he's
playing at the moment look at score he
has a plus score against Erie of three
to one
don't call him an underdog and Geary of
course losing yesterday cannot afford to
keep up that negative trend or else
he'll be in a lot of trouble somebody
who is not in any trouble after round
one is this man Yong Nepal Miyaichi
the Russian he played magnificently I
called it a game of the round yesterday
the win he had against Giri I thought
about I think this is going to be the
game of the tournament it was absolutely
incredible amazing action back and forth
precise played bold play on his part and
he has jumped into the world ranks
number four on the planet that's only
behind ding lurin Fabiano Caruana and
won Magnus Carlsen that's where he is
now in the rarefied Heights he's playing
his countryman Grizz shook they have a
pretty solid results against each other
will they continue that a solid play in
this game this has just been truly an
exciting tournament so far as you said
yes sir it feels like it's been like a
week we've applied with it one day can
have so much drama and it looks like
we're gonna have it again today
Thank You Maurice and after this first
round results let's just take a look at
how that impacted the live rating
alejandro yeah we had this before
yesterday's round had a slight reshuffle
with the decisive results you can see
that Alexander Grich who could just fell
this young upon Bianchi just a little
bit of a difference there young moving
up to fourth place and that difference
where one how he's suddenly surged
forward brings a nice giri back to 13
and one call is now ninth
actually jumped over a couple of players
in in that path you won more than five
rating points yesterday right that is
plenty and that puts him on top ten I
think for the first time in his life
yeah that looks like an all-time best no
question let's just take a look at our
pairings for this the second round and
of course we've taken a look at that
game between lvl and England which looks
like this faster for the Chinese player
Fabiana Curran is currently playing a
very complex and exciting game against
Kela Alex ANCA from Russia the biggest
rating disparity of the entire
tournament and Fabiana with white this
is certainly a game that he needs to win
I feel the pressure for family there's a
certain pressure for him to win this one
exactly yeah Nephilim yeah she's playing
Greece sharks as we mentioned and Wong
how facing off against Geary let's jump
into the game of fab' what we feel might
be well I must win game it's a little
early for that but hey look when you're
talking about the rating extremes yes
number one versus number eight number
one's got to prove why he's the top seed
and like you were saying there's a part
of these six there's a part of g4 the
King on g1 this week what is going on
yes exactly
well first of all it came from a very
sharp f3 nimzo-indian and it seemed to
me like the players pretty much were in
prep four or five moves ago now we've
just seen this ultra sharp move g4 when
we look at the time look at whoa
16 minutes two minutes left for Alex
ANCA to make his next 22 moves right he
does get increment right but Fabi has an
hour an hour and 15 vests such such a
huge edge to have that extra hour sick
whoo krill is going to put himself in a
lot of trouble
this was actually I'm just going back a
couple of moves because I really had a
difficult time understanding the
decision by fabbi to drop his Bishop
back I think that's okay but I think for
a lot of us we would say hey our bishops
under attack it got that I don't want to
take that rook and lose my bishop but
I'll develop my queen I'll develop
defend and if you move your
whether to be eight or c8 your decision
then I'll continue my development it's a
bit surprised and I didn't understand it
frankly the move Bishop h2 and then
after the move rook c8 g four again I
was thinking Queen c2 just bring the
rook into play get your pieces off the
front back row but g4 why is why did he
do that after Bishop g6
I feel it's a very concrete approach
it's a very fabi type of situation I
think we should g6 has a problem of
Bishop d3 okay and we'll continue just
the line just show rookie three you take
on g6 and I guess I'll take and then
just got just Queen d2 and you're
telling me my rook is like a little bit
it also feels like you're getting
crushed right Knight g5 is coming Knight
takes f7 might just be track made
because there's a pin with an I don't
have six Oh Queen d5 is a very real
threat
you could play roopd you'd have root
before and unfortunately first rook e1
or something like okay okay yeah well
yes decided I have to give up the piece
he didn't like some variation on Bishop
g6 he's sacrificed on he sacrificed on
g4 with with the bishop with the bishop
yeah okay so obviously I just went the
night so he's eyeballing a potential for
but it is a beast oh this is the God
it'd be good for white right I think the
N just wanted to actually do almost
miraculous the type of sacrifice and
take with the rook on g4 something like
Bishop takes g4 that takes G for jacking
h1 and this awesome move route g6
oh yeah the idea is that in this
position why am i mixing my move orders
yeah well the idea of 94 okay Jason
coming Bishop takes d6 that's deep I
thought that was very deep Wow
okay but what we got instead with Knight
takes d4 and fabbi with an extra
we're on the clock to figure things out
yeah and that's got to be huge so let's
try let's try to analyze cuz it's a
clearly black have some concrete ideas
well the whole point is this
construction the night on c7 the phone
on d6 he wants to eliminate that Bishop
on h2 yeah and on a good day if he could
ever play Bishop takes d6 hey he's right
back in the game right okay that's kind
of the key point right if I eliminate
this pawn it's almost worth more than
the exchange in a way that the bishop on
h2 if it disappears and I lose my part
on d6 oh that's just worse rates on it's
a great compensation a lot of pawns
right whereas if you take the rook on f1
yeah you took the rub but your position
is still kind of bad yeah and again at
that pawn on d6 lives okay so I'm I'm
eyeballing the knight coming to e3 as
well as Knight takes h2 so I'm looking
at moves like Queen d3 perhaps Queen c2
I'm also thinking that because I'm a
piece up I want to seize the initiative
so I mean I'm looking I know it's
probably a very bad move Queen d5 rook
takes e to Knight g5 kind of ideas I'm
trying to get the initiative let me just
put those moves on the board again I
don't recommend the move but this is the
type of thing I'm thinking about is like
I'm trying to get the initiative and
play with the piece that I have in the
hand so I'm probably gonna play Queen d3
let's just let's just put a move on the
board it's a very reasonable move it
attacks the rook it asks questions that
are not so easily answered the right
doesn't have great new treating squares
doesn't have e6 it doesn't have eight it
doesn't have 75 right that's what I was
trying to do a sucker the rook on to the
e3 square we're okay now
the knight is tethered yeah when you
take the the Bishop on h2 which is I
think what black is really wanting to do
that he's then he's on fire has played
Bishop d3 instead Bishop to d3 also
harassing this rook that has a little
bit stuck right and again eyeballing an
opportunity for like a Bishop e7 might
just win in some variations yeah exactly
yeah where where Bishop takes h7
for example if you play rookie 3 I think
Bishop f4 looks extremely strong yeah
that's just that's stone cold women IG 5
is coming because of because just
because of what you just said Knight g5
with it discovered and whites everything
everything everything so Bishop d3 by
fabbi again you know you want to
accelerate the action when your material
ahead you don't want black to just
consolidate and like we've been saying
if we if we did something less robust
something like rook c1 and allowing
Knight h2 we're just not happy you know
this is just not happiness so let's see
the procurement position Bishop d3 yeah
takes h2 what else right you have to I
think you probably also have to take on
before ok and now maybe I think the
Queen has some merit because I
understand these sixes hanging okay but
I'm balling tactics such a queen h3 or
even like wine and then queen h3 I'm not
sure they work right but I'm kind of
thinking in those lines right one of
these things might might cost you a lot
of problems okay so okay Bishop D okay
this is the current position right so
Bishop d3 he's already thinking on h2 he
has taken on h2 okay so okay if I just
chill for just one moment just King
takes h2 is with the chat sorry sir
sorry that's a well then I have to play
but you have to take on e5 you there's
no there's no choice you have to take
one or his black right and now I have a
choice I could take on the phone with
the King I could take one the phone with
the Queen I don't see anything else
there's no Knight g5 on the air so you
know it was funny because when guerrilla
played to move rook c8 I was actually
not a hundred percent sure I'm beginning
to have some regrets this black that
maybe my work should have been on b8
there's b5 and Ruby six okay let's
imagine I take with the king how would
the variation continue no want to play
Knight f6 because that hits the bishop
on e4 and it hits the pawn on d6 and
that's that's the dual purpose right
right I do I wonder if I just don't want
to take on b7 and allow the lobby to on
the other hand it's a double attack
you're hitting d6 which is my pride and
joy and I need a I need to give my
knight in a way of retreating right I
mean yeah this starts to look like too
much counter play to me 94 on the air my
King suddenly became a drip also my
bishop on e6 is like and ya know because
they're right I mean something went
wrong
yeah okay so but this is all consequent
of Bishop d3 right yeah so take stakes
we could take with the Queen we're
analyzing King take yes sorry so Knight
f6 you also have Bishop f5 that's a
temple right okay that might be crucial
but after it being I'm having trouble
defending this pawn on d6 I feel I'm
just gonna lose it and I'm not saying
that why it's worse by any means in this
position you're up piece but I cast
three pawns they're connected yeah you
start to think that it might be time to
start looking at bailout moves Murray's
jump in here yeah we said well what's
going on
I'm telling you I've been listening to
you guys and working here try my own
assessments and their story connected
passers yes I mean it really comes down
to something pretty simple and he's
taking with the Queenie you you see you
see an extra piece and we can go back to
this this moment where we have Knight
takes G for Bishop d3 Knight takes takes
takes let's let's be very real it's
three pawns you when you're up a piece
you feel like you're up you're up I'm up
a piece right you got to start counting
right when you start counting you yeah
okay whatever but I still have the piece
you really had only a piece for two
pawns so you're not really up up these
you just have an extra bit a difference
in material right that's all it is it's
just an unequal distribution of material
thing I guess the pawn back you better
be showing something you you better show
me the money because otherwise these
will be real pawns now the thing is the
pieces actually do look attractive they
look like they could be doing something
really shortly especially on the light
squares so a night landing on g5 as you
mentioned s7 might become a week so it's
all about coordination with the pieces
and also their specific purpose
otherwise Mike might start to minimize
the pieces start trading a little bit
get rid of if he could this looks like
this bishop it's so important
magnificently so if we can get that
piece off the board these Knights
usually will be stepping on themselves
and don't forget about the exposed King
there's a lot of compensation here that
block is counting on that Fabi playing
that move g4 you know he looks at
Carolyn thinks I got to get this guy
he's the bottom rating guy he's got to
be my point right but the guy's not weak
he's not weak by any stretch he might be
weaker than the elite players but he is
a 2700 okay it's $26.99 let's go all the
2700 player he can play chess and I
think that Fabi is gonna be looking at
this position a couple of moves and it's
not as much as I wanted it to be so how
does the engine try to coordinator
because he has taken with the Queen and
at this point one on the board on the
board and I do have the feeling when I
see this position that if white gets a
knight to defy for free
okay I thought the way that he would get
it here because now if I can calculate
properly Knight f6 is not playable
because I take in Queen h3 and that
looks like a very nasty double attack
exactly Knight takes hit the Queen takes
Queen h3 as you were saying hits h7 hit
c8 and white for choice no question that
looks that okay I think you have like
Knight f6 first do not to take on d6 but
you have to play Knight of six hitting
the bishop and well also giving Queen
tasty sauces and things and now I wasn't
sure because not what I wanted to ask
Maurice does 95 work because I seen a g5
picture takes h7 Queen takes still not
so sure yeah
does it work that's the question we're
looking at from the starting position
yeah 95 right there Knight f6 Knight g5
yeah yeah I'm thinking Queen d6 yeah I
was just wondering does something like
Bishop h7 have any any hopes of working
maybe not just let's take a look so far
the engines are disagreeing with you
okay queen g3 so it's just too much of
an industry this check is too strong a
nice hang at the moment so a little bit
too fast a little bit a little bit too
fast but however after Queen 66 you
can't just play Knight back to d5 and
now we're getting some coordination as
mentioned that this Knight is trying to
trade itself off we have we have in
response to this check Queen G to a
queen G to the knight nc4 sorry yeah go
on
Knight takes 94 94 Knight takes on
diploid Bishop d6 by the way big views
there Knight takes are on e4 with
everyone and what it's this ending it
looks bad for blob well no these Knights
are these nice coordinated pretty
rapidly are they're gorgeous although I
know yes sir
Queen g25 this is gonna be pressure
though yes there's gonna be pressure on
your position here I think it's unclear
I like white but it's an unclear
position but he's thinking with the
bishop okay that's really probably
plunked down that knight on d5 what you
said I'm so happy to get the Knight to
d5 for free yeah yes for Fabia fans
bobbies happy right now having seen this
transpire yeah I think that what
happened with Kirill is he became a
little bit too much of a materialist
we're all materialist when we're down
right
remember when Petrosian famously said
that when you sacrifice play like you
sacrifice not like you lost material
yeah right and you know it's always when
do I get it back where do I get it back
and in our minds we're down so let's get
that in the pocket I want to get my
stuff but it's all about coordination
it's all about the resultant
coordination of pieces and we know that
that's the only argument
white is gonna be pressing like I got
the piece I've got to get fully
coordinated grabbing the pawn back too
soon
yes you're not you cannot gain count
equality materialistically on the board
but you're not gonna be ideally
coordinated because you allowed white to
bring that night back to d5 and the
pressure is gonna be very different now
and those light squares are gonna be the
key particularly to that d5 square
because a bishop can appear on that
square as well so here this is a
completely different ball of wax from 96
absolutely it just looks like so many
threats against blacks position the
rukon see a looks really lame very
difficult to bring into the position you
have to connect the nature of whites
forces they're right they look just
beautiful
yes suggest itself for white queen aged
Wow yeah and then you start looking at
Knight g5 at all as well yeah Bishop a7
I like this Bishop a7 Queen h3 means
your queen unless your queen can't even
move virtually I mean where are you
gonna point where you got a black queen
don't even because because of rook e1
there's an eye on oh sorry you can't go
into e-file because of rook e1 right so
hireable squares because squares to go -
I can't find squares exactly like where
do you put your pieces now it looks like
the only move she's sexy she's g6 for
the moment to slow things down
yeah I'm thinking 26 as well because I
was afraid of Queen h3 and I wanted to
stop Queen Queen Asako and d7 ooh
Knight of 6 you got to defend against
now ya know I'm sorry to think that if
you go at 5 I'll give my piece back
somehow somehow there's gonna be some
sacrifice that ends the game that looks
right 95 it's coming the Queen 7 excuse
me there's a king h1 and on top at some
point also with a rook g1 I mean this is
no this looks terrible yeah agreed very
very quickly a very nice coordinated
attack but guys I mean that we to to
decisive games already 6 you talk about
the difference between your 2,500 grand
Master your 2,600 grandmas your 2,700
Grand Master your 2,800 Grand Master
write this there's small there sis tease
these difference okay between 28 25 is
big but you say well it's 2,700 like why
harder the 2700 lose to a 2800 there are
these small moments that you don't let
them pass there's these small moments
when a guy realizes wait hold on I can't
do this right just yet
yes I'm what my d6 pawn I definitely
want to put it in a pocket but I can't
do it right just yet
I've got to deal with this this idea
what's his next move right what's what's
he gonna play next and what does it look
like and when you notice 95 and you look
at the position you go wait no no not
just yet I'm gonna get the d6 pawn
there's only nine f6 first so that I can
go after this pawn properly and allowing
Bishop d7 by the way you add those
complications in the position so to me
the critical moment is like right here
right when it looked like he was
fighting right when he could just just
one more move one more patient move and
that would have been the difference
between 27 and what he would like to be
one day of 2,800 but instead he played
this very quickly getting the material
back like you know the tendency is for
all of us allowing this and now the mid
just beautiful coordination of the white
forces is starting to just hover and you
look at this and now he doesn't have
much time on his clock but to look at
this position with no time on your clock
that's there's gonna be very hard to
defend and krills down to eight minutes
we we've only looked at two games and
the round is we're deep in in the round
currently see how I was doing like he's
crushing exactly when we came on air we
had this position after Queen g2 f4 as
Maurice was showing with the breaking
news report b2 before moved that we were
expecting as well it looks extra pawn
and great position for white I mean this
King on h6g says born a Dean Lehren is
going to have to redeploy that Knight to
f6 ASAP now how about our other
tournament co-leader
we have Wang now against onigiri onigiri
again didn't lose a candidates game you
know famously went 14 draws right yeah
lost and stands worse today
oh well talk to us a little bit why you
think that white is worse okay isolated
queen pawn isolated queen pawn I like to
play against isolated queen pawn it
really depends upon the dynamics like if
you put the knight on e4 the rook on e8
you've got the C file Black has play but
the problem is this move yeah trading
off the Queen's into an endgame is
really benefiting white and after the
move f2 f3 we can just see that Wang
house play is very easy for the first
player he gets a plight rook c1 he gets
to play King f2 of course the bishop on
g2 is nobody's it's not a favorite but
it's going to redeploy and it's just
easier for white these positions what I
really black he's having to play guys
like yes Assyria I mean you're sitting
there and you're thinking this is this
guy's best dream life you have no kind
of play anywhere at all he may not win
the game but he knows he's got you on
the hook right and he's playing with you
talking around you know I'm gonna make
you suffer
and make you suffer and make you suffer
there's no easy liquidation you better
play precisely because I'm gonna be
squeezing you maybe for the next three
hours and you're gonna enjoy how it
feels it's gonna be painful and in the
best kind of way I mean this this is
just pure suffering yeah and by the way
this is the worst part for a niche yeah
is this the composition he would love to
have is white exactly like you got no
chances and I can't lose this is just
his nightmare position to be playing now
the next game that is also very
nightmarish no candidates
would be a candidates tournament without
a Burrell and I know it was very strange
right earlier I thought that this is all
standard stuff this looks like rook h6
all fishy and Hikaru and just tons of
players play this now what happens over
the next several move however is very
strange
already allowing the move Bishop b4 and
in fact provoking this doubling of pawns
you know has me scratching my head let
me just this has been played before
okay several good good good we're in
theory now what happens next is again
for me a very deep head scratcher okay
after this no King f8 look I'm thinking
that the rook is good on d1 but neppo
decides that B force the square yeah
okay and I was always taught that in
these Berlin and dings you don't want to
force black to push his Queen Saipan so
so a lot of strange moves now Bishop t2
like okay that makes room for this move
I get that that's okay
well he's transferred the rook to f3
which maybe he could have done quicker
okay then the next thing right here okay
we should see one it this move to me
shows that white White's positions a
little bit bankrupt of ideas like he
doesn't know what to do next so he says
my bishop could be a potential target
now to my mind 97 as a siren call that's
basically saying hey I'm gonna redeploy
my knight to some nice squares on the
Queen side
I like check out the last move necklace
just play the move g4 sharpening up the
position okay well he can see the
handwriting's on the wall he's got to do
something very very soon before black
just simply takes over oh you're an
Apple fan there's one good thing yes
look at that time I mean this is exactly
what you expect from a net
mr. game right never up more time that
five years against I like saying Co if
that was one hollow one hour Wow okay
yes no well I could have predicted that
before the game start I just didn't know
after three hours but we've got some
breaking news with you Maurice what's
going on
absolutely yessir and indeed we have a
position where this is so bad there's no
coming back
there's absolutely no coming back he is
now on the direct path is MVL with this
move Queen to e4 check King back there
are multiple ways he could have won he
could win this position it moves he
could have played before but it all
comes down to breaking up the team here
this structure is horrible takes here if
you take back with a pawn this pawn is
gonna come under fire from everything
we'll just put a move on the board this
move Knight f3 hitting the three part
the e pawns hanging is gonna be a bishop
c3 citing your position is just simply
going to collapse after that if you take
with the bishop the engine wants to be
cute you don't have to be this is
crushing Knight of three but d4 opening
up this diagonal for the bishop what a
move takes Knight back you're getting
ready to put the bishop on this line
your bishop drops back and in this
position Knight g5 there is a direct
assault on your position there's a
ninety six check coming
I mean who this is a whole this is not
even losing the game this is getting
completely smashed
ding Lauren will go 2-2 the second
highest rated player in the tournament a
2800 no more he's under 2,800 now he
came in with aspirations he was the
betting favorite I saw tons of math
saying this guy was a little edge
against Fabi if I'm that surprising but
nevertheless I would have said one of
the top two players for sure looking now
like he's gonna tumble to last place
after this round it's just unbelievable
he ding Lorenz 2019 was phenomenal I
mean he just played the best chess of
his career became top three in the world
I mean hello around it what having
winning against MVL yeah in in such
great fashion be a sweet revenge for
Mexico I know I'm telling you and Ford
Engler in
it just doesn't get any worse the worst
start from imaginable losing with the
white pieces in round one and now I mean
we talk about the total crush the MBL is
just the grand chest or when I'm ruining
your world indeed we make we can't put
too fine a point on it in these
tournaments you want to start off strong
the player who's in form wins the
tournament the one who's the hottest
it's generally and that was oh he got a
lucky break here like you knows the one
who's playing well and we're looking for
right away Chris trick said it after
round one he said we all play badly oh
except maybe never he played well so we
have a situation where we're looking at
the form of the players now I don't
think I think he overstated it although
MV I might say I didn't play well the
first thing I don't think Fabi played
badly in round one although I think he
could have tried for more he didn't
really go for it I believe it as he
should have allowing that position to
equalize itself a bit too quickly but
nevertheless the kids they played badly
it's an interesting game so you're
looking at MV out you're looking at
Bobby you're looking at net bow if
you're looking for players on Form and
you're looking at Wang how those are the
players
we will now naming as the ones who may
start distancing themselves and the
others don't get their act together
Ziegler no.2 trying to get it don't let
it be O to it and why now B 2 O trying
to make up that kind of ground boy is
rough and by the way when you start
losing games it's so mean the Sharks
come out yeah
they smell but is it were you looking
for who's on for him they're looking for
who's all form right go get that guy
right and so bad news for him right now
and we can look at some of these stats
from Fast Facts we say you can lose in
this tournament but you gotta wait a
while we have four events the recent
events from 2013 to look at and the
winners look how they did almost all of
them lost during the tournament but they
waited until later Caruana and Berlin
the last
he didn't lose until around 12 we're
talk about a 14 round event carjacking
in Moscow didn't lose until 11 Einon was
plus three with no blemishes in his 2014
win and Magnus lost - but his first one
didn't come until around 11:00 he was
doing extremely well he even lost in the
last round I was able to win on
tiebreaks so then if you're gonna win
this and the only thing you can do is
win it to matter at all you've got to
lose late you got to start off strong
that's the bottom line
you got to start out strong and maintain
it for a while we saw there that Wang
Hao is the seventh seed he won his game
that's the same thing that car yakin did
as seven seed he also when ended up
winning the tournament so don't think
just because you're seven seed you can't
win
it's been proven done before this 17
isn't bad reminds me Andrew might is
reminding me of Wesley of the last
candidates where what sorry started 0-2
and then he just disappeared
right he just drew his way out of the
tournament basically I mean recovered
never recovered from the harm never
recovered and this is what you need such
psychological presence to be able to
come back from two straight defeats just
horrible defeats by the way yeah I mean
the way that he had such a nice position
yesterday he was pressing against Wang
Hao it just seems like such a dingle
around position he plays f4 criticized
around the world for this move it moves
the game and then today he just gets
wiped off the board in his favorite
variation of the Spanish I mean amazing
I just wanted to play a quick game of
catch-up in the game of fab' just as we
saw at Bishop takes D 695 we expected
this move g76 because the idea is this
LightSquared bishop is actually it
doesn't have a counterpart so if you're
in black shoes you want to try to
neutralize that Bishop and the move g7
g6 makes perfect sense
Queen h3 don't reach for the F the
mountain we already saw that f5 would be
walk right into a sacrifice so King g7
covering some squares dancing as
potential Queen h6 and 95 yeah it makes
perfect sense and
each one by Fabio I would have I would
have been reaching for the rook myself I
can try prefers Bishop f5 right it
prepares Bishop f5 yeah because if you
take group then one and then you're okay
and please jump on the engine points out
this really spectacular idea they should
have five in any way just do it really
just an aftertaste King f2 okay but kick
the point is to get the King out of the
way I guess it wants to centralizes came
for the winning end game that is gonna
be playing for or maybe preserving the
h1 square for a rook as well in some
variation that could make a point but
it's tough because eight now that's the
key night if a looks so strong but Rho G
one check look G at this point I might
have just started giving up right I go
into g6
when I wrote G 199 g5 and how do you
stop the attack on the light squares
page six looks like it looks looks like
a mean and knight of seven coming
straight at you beautiful hold on let's
just continue this line please because
you can defend it with the Queen after
95 oh okay
95 Queen Queen and nobody you know where
you're putting it here like where do I
put my Queen right yeah you got to
figure out a square the problem is after
any Queen defense Queen takes on that
five and suddenly there's just monster
bull Queen of six check is a threat in
the position so I'm two pawns down but
I've got all the play and you got all
the play and don't forget the rook h1
idea that might show up at any point and
yes 97 is a threat I mean amazing
attack like amazing but yeah I might
have stopped is why why go into this
right but now having said that Bishop a5
that's a beautiful beautiful beautiful
move but King Jiwon it keeper me king h1
sets that all up to five blade remember
that achelous in very deep time pressure
so you play 95 trees is a night age for
I have Suman trying to play well Knight
a5 yeah now you just continuing the
direct path he's still definitely under
control here but the pieces are hovering
and sacrifices abound working one coming
ideas night at five ideas Maurice you
were talking about that material
imbalance of three ponds yes like okay
what black really desperately wants as
an endgame trade but with the piece what
you've got to do when you've got the
piece is coordinating the attack or this
is what we're seeing with this move
Knight h4 he's keeping as many pieces on
the board is fabbi and he's saying I'm
going to attack you and by the way
you've got no time what is minutes forty
seconds for Kirilenko three facing the
barrel of a gun I mean I know five Ruchi
what just looks like it's game ending
right I need to find a defense right now
your and your queen can't help because
your rook on c8 remember you talked
about that maybe I'm ba and it should
have been off that Square we're gonna
see it is hanging how do you coordinate
everybody is somehow you could pick your
rook up and put it on h5 maybe brilliant
could we like just help bring another we
don't have that many pieces could we
bring the pieces to help but you can't
even in Mecca that's impossible in this
position right you can't imagine how to
do that
your queen can't come over that means
we're talking about the knight the
bishop and the pawns trying to hold back
the tsunami that's about to hit night
because white has count them five pieces
that are going to be hovering around
that King you're just gonna have more
numbers than the eye can bring to defend
and don't try pushing pause because
sacrifices are going to abound so how do
this is this is hopeless
well Carol came up with a weird move age
five I was gonna suggest h5 strangely
enough the idea was I'm seeing rook g1
rook Jiwon I'm dead but I'm thinking I
can play try to plug up the G file with
the move Knight g4 so that's why I
needed it h 5 h 5 h 5 on the board let's
see what favi starts to think Oh
delicious
I'm just want to sack something anywhere
everything wins I mean at this point
it's just such a bad position thinking
on g4 I would be shocked to snot win but
you could probably take it slow right
there's no there's also some ideas of
quean a quean c3 I'm sorry yes but no
what I was saying is I didn't agree so
much with Maurice about the 2700 part
about Knight f6 right when creel had
that choice I thought Knight f6 just
screamed to be played right it's a talk
and you can take all these the Queen you
want to take with the Queen up with the
bishop right but when he plays the move
rook c8 yeah that's where I feel a
difference between us 2,700 2,800 nice
because they 2800 say say down the line
this rook is not good on see it it's on
b8 that I needed there this and this and
this further down the line this subtlety
and you can see it here how many times
does the rook been hanging how many
times has the rook needed to be in a
position where it wasn't being attacked
and fibers used it tactically so many
opportunities this Queen on h3 attacking
the work on c8 right what's the real
combi a time Bishop f5 even Bishop f5
I'm not saying that in Korea was out of
danger right but it just made his
position that little bit better yeah
that that subtlety between the rook
being on b8 and rook being on c8 that is
the 28th and find it yeah absolutely
again again you're absolutely right
about the rook c8 idea yeah no decision
I salutely know us again though when in
trouble the move that you expect them to
find you know it's just I just
consistently see the art of defense
right that's the difference yeah so
we've seen that yeah without any
question you go pre mm right defense was
starting to get good right but it wasn't
quite there yet but this generation the
generation of the engines the ones
ooh-hoo yeah they say oh we're gonna
attack we're gonna sack of the
like tall and they go yeah tall used to
do you know star polite he was creative
and all but there was mistakes here
mistakes here mistakes there when
they're not intimidated anymore and so
when in trouble the the move you need to
play right now
20800 find it what I need to do right
now you find it so that kind of moment
with nine of six he needs to play it
right then he he would see that give him
give him 50 minutes on the clock a
different circumstance he looks at it
but but this particular situation when
he needed to find 9 f6 with little time
on the clock
the bosses find those kind of moves and
that's why it's so hard for the 21 just
to defeat each other because it just
keeps being situational that they're
able to play well this situation is
horrible
why rook G 1 this H 5 idea is not going
to help because guess what it's all
about the math folks 9 to 5 is going to
crush you and we have Rho G 1 on the
board the reason why we can we can
afford to start sacrificing stuff no
problem we have enough wood on this side
to get the job done you don't need more
than you need just enough and yeah with
that request don't see it you might
think you can bring your queen over
maybe well obviously you can't because
of Bishop c4 but you'd be thinking to us
like that but with the rook sitting here
I think it actually does even matter in
this case no it's just too much wood on
this side and your king is being blasted
so 94 the h5 idea with the idea of play
Knight g4 simply doesn't work he's now
realizing it he's stopping to think
about the position he cannot play Knight
g4 he doesn't have a two-minute Oh to
take meditate all day all he can do
right now is a genuflecting where's the
miracle something happened to save me it
ain't coming because he gives here comes
furious
Fabiano Carwin rep g'wan beautiful move
threatening Knight f5 and just that nice
movie you sit there and go oh there's no
Knight F to check you're in a pin Bishop
takes f5 and Alejandro that's just
that's just lights out that's it you
just can't play it no you got
night defending of this position and
that night is pinned and the H bones
gonna drop and nobody can help and
that's it we're talking about two
minutes left for Carroll LX & Co you
could give him an hour now now just
means that this game will be over soon
that's what that's what it means here
coming into this game I thought that
there was a lot of pressure on fabbi to
perform because of the extreme rating
differences between the number one and
number eight you're coming is number one
you got to prove it you got to beat the
number eight guy I think it's such a
difference between this candidates and
the others because even the last seen on
any other candidates
you couldn't mention who that was yeah I
asked you who was the last seat in the
previous candidate it would immediately
have that available right right it was
somebody money was sucking or difference
between hacked yeah I was so packed you
didn't have that feeling that the first
seat had to be the last seat right but
in this one it starts to feel that way
Carroll in trouble yesterday yes still
getting blasted today right I mean he's
a strong player I get that he's very
strong she's just not this caliber and
people are starting to see this guy has
he stepped it up from 2700 to 27 six
sixty in his preparation of the last
couple of months right and this is the
test yeah absolutely and let's just go
back to the get all Russian matchup for
just a second because when we left it he
we just seen this very important move g4
yes and I was very curious to see how
Alexander Grisham was going to handle g4
because again I was really getting the
feeling that
Grichuk was getting ready to take over
the light squares and just you know
don't push any action please
yan remain passive before you continues
please please let's just let's just be
sure on this because okay I see Carol's
clock as you know we got yeah this is
the my he's now at and it looks like it
has happened in the game do I have moves
no I don't have mows yes 19 last 14
seconds online I mean right is maybe
this is not totally up to date but I
have seconds ticking down and we need a
move we see no real a move rook g1 is
the last move so this is what we have I
now have all zeros on my clock played by
SHINee fans plays left two seconds it
did finally have to move so let's just
make sure we pay attention because to
the - you know there's a decisive game
the decision is about to occur right
there's no question a decision there but
I gotta tell you it looks so
overwhelming I don't see any problems
here I think that what's the move though
for Knight xh5 looks like lights out
right first of all where do we even move
the King King g8 I could mean oh you're
taking h7 right King h7 otherwise I was
just thinking of this it's gonna take
right I was thinking you go Knight f4
you take on H - that looks like you
resign right making very very good are
you human here I got no I got nothing to
say where is it I got it right yeah that
looks crushing but the engine gives
another body blow which I think he's
going to be looking at I'm sure he's
looking at night at five but it gives
night at night takes on g6 immediately
instead of what night at 5 7 9 fi night
oh sorry I just went there
Knight takes g6 yeah and then if you
take with the pawn yeah yeah then night
the night at 4 move with the night east
6 9 H 5 coming IG said everything every
every don't think about Queen d4 either
yeah it's a Royal fork and again this I
mean look at this beautiful coordinated
attack against the g6 one well there's
nobody to help yeah you've got nobody
can even play rook c6 is a bailout
because it'll just be snapped off the
board and then 96 check his back so
there's nobody to help this is a light
Square attack when you have a dark
square Bishop material looks even look
looks like you're actually are up the
piece distribution looks even but in
fact the attack is plate taking place in
an opposite color of your
so you're in effect down a piece what
black would give to trade as bishop in
for a light square bishop switch colors
somehow so you that can help out with
the dark square bishop is of no
consequence in this position and the
attack displays itself that's a beauty
one nor let's see let's see he must be
looking at both moves there's no
question about it
Knight f5 is solid is crushing we know
that's gonna work but boy would you
rather play Knight at five or ninety six
yum-yum-yum
[Laughter]
stylistic but I gotta tell you I mean
when when I saw the move Knight h4 and I
saw the move rope do you want I mean he
was playing for five said a you said be
now you gotta say see with Knight a5 but
having said that Knight g6 looks awesome
- crusher do you think he's gonna play
again when you start looking seriously
looking at night takes g6 and you just
only got to look like way to see what he
does it's exciting I think barb Lee now
we can move away for a moment from this
game but you know you know this may be
the only victory of the round no but
this will be one of the most important
victories for sure because onto the show
somebody was predicting two wins and two
draws again we're being treated to some
fantastic I want you guys are mentioning
two wins by y5e and MDL shortly
absolutely crushing but I look at the
other games I don't think there are
clearly drawn us know I sorry I I just
wanted to go to our other tournament
co-leader you
this is the one I wanted to see yeah
there's very quickly right okay we saw
we this is this is where we left off
right Knight to c6 okay all right
typical Berlin kind of Riemann ubers
saving the pieces avoiding e6 brakes and
by the way bishops of opposite color
middle game and pawn on h3 is a
potential target
I like wants to play 96 I'm not really
sure why e6 it's not a move here e7 e
six well I kind of want to take on e5 e6
oh you want to take on c7 here I thought
I could throw in g4 because you can't
move the knight right right and then I
take on c7 and I think your structure is
am I missing something
well your knight still can't move all
right stuck here's a stock on your
structure on the queenside
okay he didn't play it he played King g2
and by the way e5 e6 is a move that Yan
and everybody from Kabara to play i
learned it because in Astana right like
you just look at he's six out of every
Berlin position you by the way I mean
there are certain moments in the chess
world that you know are fried into our
brain that was one of those okay so that
is a move that white is aspiring to he
played King g2 and well just looks like
a very solid nothing much happening okay
here I could say again wang hao versus
unleash you better jump to now this
before it's too late
it's not clear though he didn't drop the
hammer the way he could have although he
definitely is owning this game though
they'll get me wrong he's definitely
owning the game but he has turned it
into an endgame more technical to fair
King f6 and then the move Knight d2 and
rook g8 I believe was played is that on
the board everything as well so the D
pawns dropping the engine by the way
giving b7 to win in this position
because of the move rook
one coming with all kinds of energy as
you can't you're taking on d5 you're
gonna drop your bishop on on b8 in the
long run and got a 94 sighting
so definitely crushing definitely
crushing it's not that mating attack and
simple but you look at it now it does
clear up the cobwebs yeah yeah that
right I mean a nice huge huge advantage
is usually oh sorry I so this is a game
that we and this is finally the other
tournament co-leader game that we've
hardly paid attention to and it's
onigiri basically thrown backwards
he is definitely trying to hold the
position and how is he doing oh I like
this 9g actually sorry because this pot
on f3 is just controlling my knife in
such a bad way right it's so permanent
the knight on f6 obviously can never go
to d5 because of my isolated pawn h5
even if the pawn wasn't on h5 such a bad
square so the Knights terror so the
Knights terrible and I need to move it
somewhere and sometimes you're kind of
hesitant to move a night from f6 you're
like but I like 98 it reroutes now so
knowing then I'd get some strength it
can go to e7 where it also difference d5
if I need to but I can also go to f5 and
go to c6 it just makes sense
listen when when you look at it it's
such a good move but it's so hard to
play right right a knight back on g8
yeah you're thinking to yourself I want
to go forward I don't want to go
backwards Bishop c3 Bishop h6 roof d3
let's speed up and breaking news indeed
big results we are now predicting that
this game will end in a draw between
Griffith and his teammate Russian friend
as well I don't know how good buddies
they are I remember he came in here and
said yeah yackin wasn't his friend like
that his Droog his friend like that so
maybe they're not drugs they're not
homies but this one here rook da were
expecting to see mass liquidation of
rooks and then get to this visual
opposite color ending and we can safely
predict that this one will end in a draw
by the way I remember that interview too
and the drugs I like that I mean we
don't have Christmas together okay
advantage how it's a lot of play
obviously it's not dead dead dead but
again yeah no means but as Maurice was
saying you know Anatoly Karpov is gonna
just torture you for a long long long
time
remember Anatoly winning a very nice
game against Boris Spassky this kind of
isolated Queens pawn ending and also
Garry Kasparov in a world championship
match it feels good
specifically from this position yes how
do you continue I guess it isn't in this
point its blacksmith let's just make a
move in the position just a pass okay
somewhere key okay because that perfect
can play it on the diagonal I'm just
wondering you put your bishop on f1 yep
what's your strength winning plan here
you probably want to play III and I'll
make a pass just to make a point right
and then what is your going what are
gonna be your next was I want to put her
in h7 to me think on fate it might run
into that you might walk into Bishop
before I'm gonna get give me something
over there for me I remember this very
well from that larceny he said to me yes
sir when you're playing against the
isolated queen pawn you want to win it
you want to win it so you know
eventually what you want to do is
retreat your knight from a d4 and you
just want to you know seriously you just
want to simply assault this bond maybe
some with some preparation for me we do
have a draw
officially between the Russians young
and metric has drawn against authorship
we already expected that right so we can
to winning upon winning the pawn so I
mean I think maybe Knights d4 to c2 is
maybe a little bit too early I'm
thinking that as white I would start to
excuse me I want to put the King back on
h7 I would like to improve my pieces a
little bit the bishop on f1 maybe my
rook on d3 okay let's just say Knight C
to the idea very directly is
eyeballing Bishop f6 I'm not immediately
a night before we should have sex I want
it to all right let's pawn but not night
c2 right now right cousin I see two
losers
I walk into c2 and Knight f5 and then
you're hitting you're killing me you're
killing you are killing III I beg your
pardon
okay I have to do it hmm okay so what am
i doing I'm not that coordinated with my
pieces because when you move the rook
from the third rank that your three pawn
really suffers indeed it does seriously
this is like really weird okay let me
play Bishop e2 okay I might be thinking
about g4 I'm not a hundred percent sure
what I'm thinking about at the moment
but now you can see and you're
absolutely right Alejandro that the
knight on f6 to g8 to e7 was a very good
idea to redeploy otherwise you were just
getting so passive Lee now the knight on
e7 is actually working yes
Bishop e2 I do see it as a torture for
black but you're absolutely right it's
not that easy to just get the
coordination I want I want my knight on
f4 hitting this pawn on d5 exactly down
I think is the illusion of the double
works on the D line yeah it's like
they're not really working because the
97 guards everything like yeah unless
you put unless you put a minor on that
pawn you have nothing
I love that point the the rooks are kind
of clumsy because one single night is
holding them back yeah perhaps they need
better and block to you yeah they need a
better square okay I've got an idea
this should be to here's the idea okay
you're gonna love this okay I wanna see
means I know Knight a5 wasn't winning
but okay okay you're gonna love this
oh where is this Bishop going I just
hear I want to tie you down I like it if
you're gonna get the Bishop to b3 lady -
yes certainly isn't go for it Maurice
break
indeed and now he's excited having a
sacrifice alert and he has occurred he
did play the move would he guessed we
guessed night at four he played it
Knight g4 instantly played and Knight
takes on h5 smashing through in the
position cracking the position opened
pawn takes has been played and we're
expecting at any moment to move Knight
to f5 check we do have the piece sac as
anticipated this position is collapsing
rapidly the H pawn is gonna drop the
knight on g4 is dead to the dead tall
rights to the world it looks like
probably still waiting he still sing
calm in this moment but we expected the
decisive blow to be landed at any moment
from beyond the Caruana surging right
now that the contender from the last
championship cycle looking to now show
that he indeed wants to challenge Magnus
yet again by winning very quickly you
want to win early in this and get that
momentum because this win could just
pick up his confidence and he is the
number one seed by a long wait now by
the way separating himself even more so
from ding Lorraine who is just dropping
like a rock Bobby will be out rating
everyone in the field by like 50 rating
points yes when this is when this round
is over so that even if big will only
get him in a tie for first with young
indeed indeed well if he wins we're
always working right that said nobody in
this field was to see Fabi get high no
you don't want anybody to get high but
not that dude no way we know what he
could do he could simply beat everybody
when he's on fire he just comes from
such a spectacular tournament truly
spectacular event in vikon's they see
their Fabiana Khurana
here in the st. Louis chess club the guy
with the guy streaks I know it's just
amazing it's crazy let's make a point as
well there there is it chess is a
zero-sum game that's just the way it is
if I win you lose if you're in trouble I
love it when you're even if I'm not
playing you for Fabi to see ding Lauren
going down then his spirits lifts
oh yeah keep killing that guy I hope he
keeps playing badly I don't need him to
think that he could come back I want to
separate myself and show that I'm the
boss of this tournament and everybody
knows that I'm indeed the number two
player deserving of playing Magnus
Carlsen just to finish the variation
that you have Maurice okay
Knight f5 I assume is winning and what
is the correct continuation after just
moving the king up yeah I was about to
say is suicidal g8 a suicidal g6
so f6 is the only move it's not like I
wanted to okay and by the way now that
you're not in a pin Knight f2 I was
thinking that his intention was just to
chill it's just easy that's it and your
king Chuck win right so I was wondering
if I was missing f1 is convincing enough
yeah that H pawn is flimsy the knight is
doing nothing the rook on CA the bishop
on FA we do expect a surge into the game
somehow to defend the poor King have
this kind of situation with a student
where you go rook f1 and the student
goes yeah you're right now you go no no
don't give up you owe me remember the
Russian commentary and French commentary
and could easily do English commentary
as well but I remember the argument I
got in with her and in the end you and I
said okay you're right you're right she
said situation we resign I was laughing
so hard I hurt
I remember I was playing I was like I
was B I was playing wynton marsalis
actually the great jazz musician he
didn't know it was I was a grandmaster
playing a prank on him and he was
playing a game and his friends as he's
playing he thinks he's playing just some
Joe Schmoe off the street and and so I'm
beating him and he goes his friends go
resign and he goes I never resign you
know other guy to give up just keep
playing we're going to call our friends
over okay okay he's yes he played by the
way Brooke d3 to d2 trying to avoid any
of those Knight a5 tricks I lied I
appeared can we take a look at the MV
again because you see a couple of moves
and that's non play Knight a5 by the way
he played Bishop f5 which I'm assuming
is just as winning actually looks just
as winning sorry you wanted to take a
stinking 92 he didn't play b7 as
expected to play movement he 6b7
with the idea Ruby one was the computers
first choice indeed
okay you can't play Knight takes c6 that
would be suicidal after Bishop takes
right here
okay so rook takes was forced no okay it
looks really bad if I just play
something like Knight world rook b1
threading b7 right I assume you have to
play Bishop d7 to prevent that okay
that's actually winning a p3 sprint guy
sorry yes another count 13 seconds walk
for Carroll mercy only now down to eight
waiting for a move he's finally moved
and he did play it was 10 seconds left I
look like when he's jump back to 110 so
that's a bit strange I thought was a 30
second increments jump yeah back he
looked like he owed me a 10 second
Bishop e7 now clearly Bishop g4
shouldn't just end the game right all
right yeah
mate I mean what do you do this is just
a toss move with no time on the clock
there's no way fabi's not gonna just
take this piece you're not gonna take
the rook obviously it's gonna take this
Knight and then he's just gonna waltz in
this is resign a bow just the last
throws death throws as Kira will go down
it'll go down to a complete crush the
problem when you're playing in this
tournament the lowest rated player
playing against the big dogs is losing
badly you'd like to lose some long end
game show that you had spirit show that
you had fight don't let the guys say no
no you're not good enough we're coming
here to destroy you and the moment you
start trending badly we're gonna keep
pushing you in that direction and right
now probably showing dude I'm telling
you don't belong on the stage with no
that's how he's that's how he wants to
be a boss in this kind of game yeah yeah
absolutely and by the way Bishop takes
g4 it looks actually like force mate I
mean yeah I like some Bishop g5 or
something yeah this is you don't play
you're just resigned yeah because you
just look at you're looking at a v1 and
if you go back you're looking at mate
and one oops excuse me that was a mouse
lip that would be horrendous made in one
so it's just looking like bitching mate
for husband played and we're waiting for
know he has taken really he is taking
the momentum is just pushing him forward
right now right he's just men and make
any move that he could make in the
meantime but of course we Robbie vet
with too much time on his clock and he
we need to come we used to say that in
my day that when our opponents was an
extreme time trouble he didn't have
enough you know you're playing on
adrenaline
yes also you don't want to lose under 30
I know in the new book of short
a long time from now
yeah I mean it's will call this one in a
moment probably didn't even take the
bishop excuse me puppy break queen h5 in
this position please it's not gonna
obviously play up six because you're
going to get murdered by this Knight
Queen just let us know when he recites
but what's going on cuz 98 I see a b7
and that's what we've done
what's going on what happened was we saw
rook e1 we kind of assumed Bishop Bassam
was forced except it was it wasn't yeah
b7 is the big threat threatening to
strap apiece and the alternative was
probably the best chance for ding lurin
he played night to d8 stopping b7 and I
don't know King takes f5 and black is
I'm comfortably still kicking 1698 is a
massive blunder oh really
massive massive blunder because it
doesn't stop these 7:07 stop b7 you
can't take with the night because you
your your bishops action 94 kills and we
do have a finish in the Caruana game
okay mercifully he resigned finally but
now Bishop takes b7 and look at all
those scrumptious pieces lined up the
move Bishop a5 and there's nothing you
can do your bishop can't leave because
of the bishop or mb8 Bishop takes Knight
is the threat and how do you just you
just BC you're nothing and that's it so
night d8 seals his fate if he was trying
to board Hillary
b7 now on the board so back-to-back
we're gonna see from two boards
victories happen almost simultaneously
probably just one and now we see mvl
about to win b7 is a is a knockout punch
and by the way we were talking about
black winning with winning with black
yesterday yeah not today today but I
took it on the chin twice horribly and
is suffering in the other game vicious
takes me 7 played Bishop a5 played
instantly by nvl I expect ding there in
to just throw in the towel that is a
full piece and here we go 2-2 is gonna
go to - Wow
well you talked this talked about this
not only yesterday bit at the top of the
show today
Maurice losing in the candidates you can
lose but you got to lose late you can't
lose early and losing two games anybody
ever come back from that kind of death
to win know they just know you might go
tall because I'll actually did lose two
games early in his campaign he lost his
first game okay he lost his first game
he won his second game that she didn't
lose two in a row and he won his second
you he lost his third game so he didn't
lose two out of the first three which is
a pretty bad start with anyone the next
game and broke back to even so bounced
back you know he did that he had to at
least do that then he drew his next game
and then he started when he won three in
a row so he was able to write the
so it's it's but to lose and then lose
again man this is a Herculean task right
now for ding Lorraine you can almost
write him off and out of the tournament
now well you can't say that has to be
the case but the oddsmakers whatever you
add up here
his stock just dropped precipitously as
he has lost so he I don't think he's
resigned yet Bishop a5 on the board
still but his his disastrous beginning
looking at him here I mean you couldn't
look this is not the yeah Catherine
burger this is st. Louis right but this
is the look of a man who has all his
hopes and dreams he prepared for months
after winning the grand chest or he
prepared four months he was this
environment he skipped events he said
this is it this is my dream come true
you cannot put too fine a point on this
these players get very scant
opportunities every two years to be able
to challenge exactly the best player on
the planet
you can age out as young stars are
coming they're not sitting back there's
all kinds of young stars who are hungry
for their opportunity to come to the
world stage
so when you get a chance like this you
know it's huge its massive opportunity
in your career he'll be back no question
about it he might even be back in this
tournament will see the fortitude he can
show like you hate when your one chance
the candidates itself is staring at you
and you don't do it you could be
depressed and a month it's done he asked
resigned
everybody let's talk about MDL he comes
into the right and boom last one from
the get-go
he did start with two whites but what a
way to begin I've seen these Cinderella
stories time and time again and VL
incredibly depressed incredibly
disappointed that he didn't make the
candidates I mean he came so close in so
many different ways whether it be the
World Cup the Grand Prix rating wise
every kind of way he could qualify he
was just like half in yeah yeah and then
suddenly he's invited as one of the
players Timur steps out and he sort of
like what you giving me a chance
and guess what today he's tied at the
moment he's tied for first he just
played
Fabiana Caruana and Bing Lauren and he's
plus one dad first right he says the
numbers one and two and said I'm plus
one against those guys right who else is
in watch out we talked about this before
this tournament is not about rating this
tournament is about hunger and formed
this is that's what it's about
who's the hungriest the one who wants it
the most and how well are you playing
and this specific moment in time we've
seen Bing Lorraine this is not ding
Lorraine this is a shell of himself at
the moment ding Ren is a boss think
Loretta is a superstar but if you're not
informed in an individual event the
event just passes you can win the next
one and the one after that you could
have won stuff before but if you're not
informed in that event it doesn't matter
it's about hunger when you come in and
form simultaneous you can't just want it
you've got to be hot at the right time
and it looks like we've got it it's too
early to call but we got a couple of
people at least three players I would
say if not four players who are sound of
separating themselves in our minds right
now and looking pretty good boy Fabi
looked good today yeah let's take it
again a look at the standings one big
victory stupid victories one game still
remaining a nice carry still let's say
defending against one foul in a
complicated position Americana and and
we all have won their games against
Curiel Alex & Co and England
respectively meanwhile young at home you
actually drew against Alexandra district
and therefore we have a three-way tie at
the top with one and a half points we do
expect one how to either tie with them
or surpass them as we do like his
position but we know that anything can
happen still write a two result going
was certainly favorable to Wang Hao and
what a start for him and VL by the way
when Maurice put it in those terms
I played number one and number two and I
got plus one who's left from somebody
that was just happy happy to be there
and France was so happy I mean when the
news came out that he was replacing team
or there was no like
what happened to team or maybe this is
Romney business right they were elated
exactly finally mvle gets his chance
exactly and here he s plus-1 Wow and
he's showing by the way you know the the
there's gonna be there have been
controversies around this tournament
this is probably the most controversial
candidates we've seen in I don't know
how long I don't know yes sir if you
have a memory of something this
controversial the is first of all the
extraordinary events that our world is
really are dealing with right now
with the pandemic for that to influence
the chess world all these events that
got canceled as one solved many people
saying that this should have been
canceled then right yeah Boff pulls out
and says I don't want to play not only
these conditions I think you guys should
maybe stop the tournament feed a
deciding no we're gonna do it we think
we can handle the situation regardless
that argument between them the
controversy many people still believing
that this tournament maybe maybe she's
still cancelling in some way but now
it's on then suddenly nvl appearing in
the tournament right also I'd like to
add the controversy around the wild card
system people saying maybe with the wild
card should be abolished because it
doesn't seem fair that countries can
just throw in their best player even if
he doesn't seem as though that player
will not be competitive against the top
players in the field the people who
argue for the pros of that yeah he
shouldn't be playing they're saying
today yeah that's right Kiril doesn't
belong now if he had won history would
have said something else so we this is
an extraordinary extraordinary
circumstances and by the way we should
point out that Fabiana Caruana will be
on skype with us shortly amazing all the
way from your Karen Berg after such a
victory he must be absolutely elated
we'll be chatting with him and we'll do
that on the other side of a break
Alejandra we'll take a quick one and
we'll be right back don't leave us we
still have one game remaining and we'll
have Fabiano corona america's number one
with us in just a second
okay thanks guys we're gonna take a
quick break from candidates coverage and
talk a little bit about opening traps I
have some very nice deep dark opening
secrets to share with you guys and we're
gonna start with kind of looking at one
of my favorite openings in chests well
my favorite gambits this is a Stafford
gambit and it emerges from a petrov
after E 4 E 5 9 3 9 6 Knight takes e5
black does not play in the traditional
pawn d6 but rather plays knight c6 and
after Tate's takes this looks honestly
really bad for black locks down a pawn
has these double pawns on the C file and
on top of that it's White's move and
I'll say that this opening is not
objectively good
however there's so many land mines that
white can walk into so over the next
three to four minutes I'm gonna try and
show as many traps as possible and share
why this this is a really really nasty
opening so let's imagine white plays
intriguing with your pointy five
attacking the knight seasoning
initiative black can respond with ninety
four and now let's say white gets a
little bit careless and plays one of the
most natural looking moves pawn to e3
kicking the Knights yet again it turns
out black has a winning move here and
move as Bishop c5 just counter attacking
attacking the f2 pawn and if white takes
the Knights on before this walks into
just devastation Bishop takes off two if
King takes off to the queen is lost and
otherwise king e two walks into Bishop
g4 and again the Queen will be lost for
whites so going back let's imagine white
doesn't play e5 but rather plays a
seemingly solid move pawn to d3 black
can still go ahead play Bishop c5 now
you should know this if white plays pawn
to e5 black can respond with ninety four
and that would be a direct transposition
so let's imagine white plays Bishop to
g5 here this looks very natural pinning
the knight to the Queen however this is
again a losing move Black has a
brilliant idea Knight takes e4 Queen
sacrifice after Bishop takes d8 it's a
very simple made into this is known as
the Gauls mates and white can can cry
and sadness so going back Bishop g5 is
just a blunder Knight takes e4 is is
again just winning for for black if pawn
takes Knights we have the same tactic
Bishop takes off - and the King will be
kind of driven away from from its lady
on d1 so let's look at another move
let's say Knight c3 this is probably one
of the most common traps I've seen
players fall into where white can either
start with Knight c3 or start with d3
but essentially if like gets this
position White's already in big trouble
after Knight to g4 and now we see
there's tremendous problems for white
defending f2 really the only move for a
white to try and save f2 is Bishop e3
but this gives back a pawn after Knight
takes c3 pawn takes c3 Bishop takes c3
this is a great position for black the
bishop is dominance it can be reinforced
with Queen g5 and white is really
suffering here so let's go back to our
main position after pawn takes c6 and
now I want to show my favorite trap and
the trap I'm about to show is something
I've had countless times online and it's
something that players as strong as it's
FM I am even GM have have fallen into
and it starts with very natural sequence
Knight to c3 defending the pawn Bishop
to c5 remember d3 walks into Knight g4
so let's say Y plays safe let's say
white plays Bishop to e2 it was very
safe a solid looking move black can go
ahead and play each v and I mean this is
highly highly aggressive but the idea is
to play Knight to g4
so let's say like there's another safe
move on h3 turns out after Quan age
three white is pretty much on the verge
of losing and there's a simply
incredible sequence here for black which
if you want to you can pause the video
but I'll go ahead and show it
starting with Queens Adi for threatening
means White has the the natural move to
castle here but now black is going to
continue throwing punches Knight to g4
hitting the pawn in f2 and kind of using
this fishing pole idea we're now if pawn
takes d4 pawn takes g4 whites actually
in really really big trouble here and
let's imagine white plays a move like d3
then after Queen e5 there's no defending
that make threats on h2 if pawn g3 then
Queen takes g3 is check and mates
so now I want to show the nicest line in
this variation rather than pawn to d3
let's say white plays pawn g3 and again
this is a position I've had many times
in online blitz black can continue
initiative Queen e5 threatening made in
one also threatening Queen h5 so the
only reasonable move to the fend is king
g2 and now there is a beautiful
beautiful knockout blow that should
takes f2 and it turns out white is just
going to be the fenceless let's imagine
rook takes f2 there is Queen h5 and
there's really no stopping the idea of
Queen h3 and this is pretty much
resigned wool for whites if you don't
trust me you can check with the engine
but one more line let's imagine King
takes off to the rook h2 the only way
for white not to get me then is to move
forward with the king but then after
Queen takes g3 King D for this is just a
really really fun position I've had this
position a couple of times in online
let's and the simple move to play is
Bishop e6 and this is absolutely
crushing for black but the idea just a
Castle queenside with check and continue
punishing the White King so I think
that's all the time we have I really
hope you guys enjoyed that be sure if
you do play any dirty opening traps that
you sanitize your hands very important
in this era that we live in and yeah
stay tuned from rappin for more action
and we'll be back with more coverage of
the candidates
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back through the second round of
the candidates 2020 we already have
three results of the day two of them
decisive what a way to start the
tournament
Fabiano just destroying Korea Alex anko
I'm speaking of avianna Khurana he is
with us via Skype from yeah Catherine
worth Fabi how are you doing hi good
well tell us about the game tell us
about the tournament tell us about the
conditions now that's about everything
well the game was comfortable today you
know it seemed to go pretty smoothly III
got a position from the opening which
was extremely sharp and that was kind of
what I was looking for when I played up
three and I think he mixed up his lines
or or he couldn't exactly what he was
doing and and rookie six struck me as
kind of strange but it did remain very
messy and I thought his last mistake was
probably Bishop 66 rather than 906 which
looked like a better chance to fight on
what do you feel he really went wrong or
where was your prep ending you said
rookie six struck you as weird but was
where are their most part of your prep
yeah I had prepared something but I
couldn't quite remember it because he's
never played this line before so this
was stuff that I had checked in the past
and and hadn't really expected today
so rookie six I was completely on my own
before that I was trying to remember the
theory of the position but but it it all
seemed a bit unfamiliar to me I
remembered some motives and and some
lines like rook b8 I remembered as a
movement but after rupees six I was
completely on my own okay now you
mentioned you wanted a sharp position
against him I said because specifically
it was secure like sanguine he's the
lowest rated player or is it because you
just want to get a sharp position every
game no it had nothing to do with him I
thought it could be interesting against
him because
he's seems to be a bit less experienced
in the openings in terms of preparing
for top events and preparing openings so
I thought it might be possible to get it
uh an interesting position impossible
with the slide but it wasn't because she
was his rare indeed I was just looking
for for a fight I mean in this
tournament you at some point you have to
start creating chances for yourself yeah
definitely
fabbi first of all hearty
congratulations a nice game
I just got to ask you a question because
your mothership age to really did
surprise me I think that most players
would have just played Queen d2 what
dissuaded you from Queen d2 and were you
anticipating this whole line that
happened in the game with g4 that came
later yeah I I kind of I thought the P
sock would would lead to an advantage
for me and Queen d2 I didn't really like
because of Bishop takes f3 all by rook
to e4
I thought this might be good for white
but it seemed a little bit of a mess
okay rook t4 and then it's difficult to
put my queen I mean my [ __ ] one out for
is now is now hanging it a lot of wives
it would rub much Olivia on h2 it's at
least that was my thinking and I thought
they should pitch to is the ideal move
to make I mean if he doesn't like a
piece and he really ends up in a in a
bad position and I thought the piece I
would be I kind of looked at g3 and and
kind of f6 was was my only real concern
and then I were planning to believe he
won he won which has a nice trick he
takes only four plays Queen g6 or in
person report or whatever yeah and I'm
like ninety five minutes of war and the
Queen g6 Queens you two I have this
Knight of six tactic otherwise things
work
yeah and game I think it's very pleasant
for it I'm not sure it's going to be
witty or anything but it's it looks like
a free free chance to win basically
even if I play 97 at some point and with
my rook the pieces my piece is much
stronger than his three pawns right good
judgment I like it no it definitely had
a very nice visual appeal it just felt
you were better throughout the game tell
us a little bit about the conditions
surrounding the event is it comfortable
to place it psychologically difficult
tell us a little bit about how the
players are feeling especially you I
don't think anyone's about it's
definitely not not comfortable about it
our temperature has taken twice a day in
the morning night and for example today
I show the temperature of 98.7 degrees
and this provoked a panic basically no I
I'm not even kidding like they they
called politicians to to figure out the
situation the doctor started making
phone calls and I had to go through
another screening I guess so I went
through two temperature checks it still
showed the same temperature which is the
normal temperature but apparently in
this part of Russia
98.7 counts as a fever Wow so so that I
mean everyone's extremely paranoid I
they're not great conditions to play
under but Abbi
what are your thoughts you must be as
shocked as we are watching one of your
main rivals lose the first two games of
course I'm speaking about Diggler in
yeah I think it's clear that he's he's
suffering psychologically from
everything that happens I mean it must
be especially difficult since it started
in his country and he I'm sure he has
family and friends who have been exposed
to the risk for far longer than it took
then when it started to reach the rest
of the world and and now of course
everyone is is affected by this but
but he's in well but weeks in Moscow all
these things can't be good for your
chest and I think that's uh that
explains his his poor start and for you
fabbi you came from Germany but you had
a little bit of a scare yourself in
terms of getting to Russia your flight
had been canceled in the end it all
worked out well
but you were probably a little bit
jittery yourself yeah we we found out
that Aeroflot was counseling me I was
given a visa for the 13th for some
reason at the time we were been annoyed
by that it was on the 13th but it wasn't
up to us you know the Russian government
gave it to us but we thought it wouldn't
be a big deal
we plan to arrive the 11th but okay we
changed our plans to 13th and and the
situation the world was not at the point
where we thought we might actually have
trouble getting to Russia and then a few
days before we were going believe if we
need saw announcement that had canceled
most of its flights starting at 13th and
except for flights from main hubs like
we were going to fly through deuces or
but they were they cancelled all flights
in Germany except except through
Frankfurt so then we looked for an
alternative solution and we realized
that Prague would fly direct to
Yekaterinburg which seems ideal because
Prague at the time Czech Republic at the
time had registered very few cases and
hadn't really shown any and shown much
concern that that for example they would
close the borders but the very next day
they closed their borders so and and
there was a general advisory that anyone
coming into the country would be put
under two weeks quarantine so we quickly
canceled that flight so that we wouldn't
be stuck for two weeks in Prague and and
we scheduled on the 12th in the evening
we scheduled a flight through Frankfurt
to Moscow Moscow to Catherine Berg and
one hour after we booked the flight we
left the house in Russians and we
arrived we left at 5 in the evening I
think or less in Germany time Central
European Time and then we arrived in
Yekaterinburg at 11 in the morning
the next day and I mean it wasn't
pleasant but we were just happy to get
to get here and if I may if I may
probably you you said some things that
this was really difficult conditions
probably you've never had similar
conditions the only thing I can think
about is maybe I'm not trying to play
his match against são Paulo of was it
right having to do some ridiculous
things in order to get to an event what
is the mindset of an elite competitor
like yourself when the conditions around
you may not be so great but you have to
perform well what are the kind of things
that maybe you talked about with your
second advice you might give to folks in
such a trying situation I mean I don't
know if I could give advice because I'm
not sure because it myself
deal with dealing with these things but
I mean at least one thing is that when
you sit down before do you usually tend
to forget about everything else that's
going on and I think that's mostly
because I've been playing chess for so
long and that's sort of what you have is
doing at some point you get used to it
that you whatever is going on your life
you kind of forget it when you when you
sit down but this is sort of
unprecedented I mean this case was was
was very difficult
he volcano erupted in Iceland and kind
of spewed smoke and ash all over Europe
and they pushed pones at the world
championship match by a few days I think
and he traveled through Europe in a bus
or some such situation our travel
situation wasn't that bad but the the
situation in general is much much worse
it's a it's not a volcano at something
which affects the entire world and and
has already kind of cost a lot of people
their lives so yeah it's it's not a
great situation but what can you do
fabbi last question from me before we
let you go did Vijay make the right
decision
pushing the tournament against all odds
while everybody else is canceling their
events no March Madness here in America
no NBA maxime just walked right back to
me first time laughing I'm not sure it's
too early to say it's also not not
entirely clear if the torment will reach
its conclusion without being postponed I
mean you never know what's going to go
on generally speaking I would say no I
think that it probably should have been
postponed but but it's also a very
difficult situation so I can't really
blame them for for not wanting to let it
go god knows how many months in the
future and the situation isn't
predictable and we wouldn't know we
would we'd also have this tournament
hanging over our heads for for basically
the next year it wouldn't be a great
solution either well thank you so much
fabbi good luck in the rest of the
tournament Mike watch your temperature
[Laughter]
thank you good luck yeah be nice yes
Cheers and as we get set up for another
interview I knew it was bad in terms of
this travel I just didn't know it was
bad
well the visa was a strange situation
because they had requested it for the
11th when they wanted to early Russia
gave them the visa for the 13th despite
the first round being on the 17th which
for an elite elite event it's pretty
late yeah
you know you still have the opening
ceremony before it's technically
determined starting on like the 1650 you
already have some technical meetings
right so it was a pretty late arrival
this committee
getting your medical certificate
committee I mean everybody wants to be
double-checked and also the security
just know nobody's cheating and
everything else but we do have a new
interview well hello to another winner
of the day it's Maxie Bashar like grab
joining us from your kateri work
curiously a very similar background
how are you Maxine yes I how are you
we're good they're suffering supposedly
you know safer than than the United
States in terms of coronavirus so I
should really ask you we're keeping
we're practicing good hygiene senators
sanitizing every 20 minutes or so and
just social distancing domestic but tell
us about today's game yeah I just went
very nicely I thought I got a great
position up out of the opening right and
then when I managed to cover all of his
country with night h2 for instance
yeah we love the movie night at night
yeah clamping down on the kingside but
it just seems that such a by this point
has become bad where do you think he
went wrong and you got that much yeah
because noise I mean I think if I was
misguided because I thought his idea was
get a tech okay a dish of I ate c4 and
then Bishop f6 just one text b5 Bishop
f6 context before Queen Queen f7 but the
I noticed Bishop g5 is probably very
strong so but even this I must say was
probably better for him than the game
because what happened in the game was
really really how do you say a total
we thought yeah lady food maybe yeah I
think at some point you want to put an
equal but because after Bishop I mean
like so often ith tool you probably
realized like there's no way to stop
Bishop c4 and the before so even
desperation like keep Jason King g6 but
I just take g4 and fine
why is making less safe than Ice King
especially with his bishop and I it's
just dead I mean I was still a bit
concerned after he played there for but
the language this is before and if it
takes no Queenie for track in just in g7
Knight f3 and very importantly my g8
first to Knight g4 that's a nasty move
yeah Knight f6 will have five and just
you can resign right nice so that was
the point of before and then in the game
okay Bishop d6 like Bishop c5 t4 again
Bishop d4 Knight f3 over attack again
miss bishop on a8 is just out of the
game so there's not much to hope for
exactly yeah Maxine tell us we haven't
got a chance to speak to you tell us
your feelings once you found out that
you were going to play and the challenge
it's been not being able to prepare as
much as everybody else but at the same
time being elated at the opportunity
yeah they I just expect it to happen but
yes the situation got a bit confusing
but at the same time I mean it's a great
opportunity for me so I I didn't think
twice when she they announced me that
there was a free spots
I mean first they announced me that
possibly there was going to be a free
spot so would I be you know considering
playing if that happened and I said of
course yes and then like two days later
I mean they were withdrew from the 20
maps so basically by round 14 you that
maybe there was a possibility which
means I actually no much fight much
fighting - more like wait I don't
remember okay so the fourth yeah you
were not really ready to play a
candidate's regular vacationing in New
York you're having a great time and
suddenly you have to change your mindset
in just a couple of weeks to face the
best of the best what yes considering
the situation right now it was a good
thing that I got these vacations because
I don't think I'm going anywhere near in
New York for so I cannot literally get
him but yeah enough jokes because of
course the situation right now is the
corner virus is actually very worrying
and of course I'm taking the opportunity
to tell everyone from the US from France
and from every country to stay on and
purchase so social distancing as much as
possible no matter how annoying it may
be exact you fabbi Fabiana mentioned
that everybody's getting testing twice a
day and that he actually was 98.7 how is
your testing going for you personally so
far normal like I saw some measurements
and well I don't know is it translating
fahrenheits but I was a little I mean I
was lower than 37 degrees so yes 37
yeah a little bit lower yeah I think
it's 97 in terms of I don't remember but
anyway so yeah so far it just normal I
mean of course I mean if you know
there's panic because of you know phobia
getting a bit tires and I mean 96.7 or
something of course it's a bit strange
but you know and at some point they
expect someone to to get supposedly real
fever because that's generally what
happens in such a long tournament so
we'll see how it proceeds but of course
yes they're monitoring the situation
very closely and depending on Kristen's
authorities orders the tournament might
get postponed at any moment your mindset
I had asked Bobby this your mindset that
keeps you strong well what what do you
talk to your I mean I'm talking to my
family and friends and saying stay
positive and productive keeping their
minds clear you know make sure you're
doing something don't just sit around
and watch television and get more and
more depressed find something to do be
stronger out of this then weaker be more
optimistic than fearful what are you
discussing with your friends and family
or your second right there with you I
you know you need to tell us who that is
but how do you keep a car that reminds
me there's actually nobody because there
was no time to to get anyone so so I
mean you can book alone but but of
course I have support from my family
from my friends and from my from the
people who work for me were all certain
to be to be friend friends and
especially hm and yeah you know it's
just a bit weird
- you know to be doing absolutely
nothing apart from from the chess
tournament but I guess the chess is a
decent motivator so far - you know to
keep paying attention and and well this
time I'm not disturbed by by Gian Piero
person gasps I just have to just focus
on and I got to bring some enjoyment to
the chest fans and well truly exceed you
guys are the only game in town sports
programs are really boring these days so
I mean you've got the eyes of the world
on you ya know it's it's definitely with
the experience and yeah we'll see of
course I was a situation keeps on
developing in every country and of
course I'm thinking about friends
because the situation is country not not
out of control but it could it could get
to there very soon Mexican we want to
thank you so much for joining us we want
to wish you good luck for the rest of
the tournament and stay healthy
yes we're all-star crazy if you're also
crazy Bankston we're all the same boat
yeah thank you breaking news Maurice and
the remaining game absolutely we do have
a breaking news and
it is while we were speaking Wang Hao
who will be absolutely the Shocker of
the tournament has pocketed upon against
a nice giri and is looking to try to go
to to and oh and be the clear leader in
this event man if you had said ding the
Ren was chewing oh and Wang Hao was Owen
- I think a lot of people say yeah that
sounds like normal but this situation is
completely flipped and it is Wang Hao
who's trying to press right now and
prove himself and we will show you the
position on the board after before an
itch captured on before the engines did
not like that move crystallizing the
second weakness when you have a position
we know endgame technique says one
weakness is generally not enough but the
principle of two weaknesses is that now
we're going to extend the defense we're
gonna make it harder for you to protect
your position because there's second
weakness on the board and yes you had
this pawn that was fine but now this B
pawn has become another possible victim
rook to a8 played jettisoning the B part
it's under pressure by the way there's a
bishop and a knight able to take you but
at the moment some tactic stopping him
but wang hao defended completely and
then finally played rook c1 looking to
play rook c5 and here we saw Gary
jettison the pawn and now play rook to
a3
he is currently down a full pawn the D
part we were worried about who knew the
B part will be the one that dropped in
this position plus he has this great
Bishop we'll try to push this down the
board guys this looks winning absolutely
looks like everything that you could
muscle weakness still to attack you got
a passport the bishop you got a better
better piece and you've got your rook
behind the passport that rook I'm b2 I
mean what should be 3 + b5 it's like
lights-out its technical foreigner by
the way I think that Wang Hao like many
of his countrymen Chinese players are
very good technically the the dangler in
plays an excellent technical game as
displaying how and on each Gary that was
weird I mean even before Murray started
analyzing cuz we left this a while ago
but this idea of a 6 & B 5 yeah donation
of this story very strange because
there's a bishop on f1 that it's an okay
bishop but once you put a pawn to b5
that's right my bishop on f1 I mean
suddenly work in the Spanish you go
Bishop b5 a 4 C 2 D 3 f1 so that you
have this a 6 v 5 target that's exactly
it willingly created a second weakness
in the position and that was really
shocking I think he thought he was
creating counterplay but there's always
a drawback to every idea and the
drawback here was highlighted by this
set of moves where I houses thank you so
much for push I couldn't have begged you
to hook I could I paid you money to give
me something else to target for yeah by
the way this move Knight c3 - e - it has
echoes of the move Knight of 3h - Maxime
no you you get out of the way of the
pawn storm and you say oh by the way
thank you for creating some weakness
yeah I was
he didn't sit on the position sometimes
when you're on the defensive side you
make your position a lot worse when you
go after modes like 6 b5 and I've seen
anon do this wonderfully when he gets
this kind of isolated pawns yeah I know
there's slightly worse for black and I
make them look equal like you just have
no problems at all he does nothing
why can't do anything either the
traditionals you holds with the haitian
opinions but it's so difficult for most
people to do that
me too I mean look at Gary he's one of
the best defenders in the entire world
he goes a six b-58 I'm looking for
counseling for that counter play yeah
and it backfires I'm not saying that his
plan is bad it might not be bad but his
execution at some point it was right
here it was right here by the way the
engines that don't open up the game this
was captured with the capture on before
and and crystallize and you know who's
trying to attack right why trying to
attack who wants the game more open
white because when the game opens up
like the one with the initiative will
start to speak so you better have
something when your career
my weaknesses cuz you got yours too well
this is the very interesting position
because you think you open up the a file
and the C file and look at that black is
controlling both files right now
rook on c7 and rook on 8 problem is that
once I take control over one file right
I penetrate as white yeah as black I'm
not really doing very much right these
files well the other problem as I see it
as the pawn on b5 so rookie 2 sets up a
capture and now that the pawn on b4 is
defended once more now we're gonna
capture that problem we got to play
Bishop takes b5 and now thanks for the
file that's right you've got to see them
out why because remember when the knight
was doing so beautiful work on e7 yeah
it was making the two rooks look
ridiculous on that now it looks
ridiculous as it's not participating in
the game at all and we could just move
it one square diagonally put it on the
d6 so juicy maybe land on c4 later all
everything works but no II seven poorly
placed suddenly and so happy was
weighing how that the game just shifted
to open files a separate weakness to
attack as well and that night on deep on
e7 by the way the bishop on d7 only a
defensive piece as well so everything
wrong with this plan of advancing on the
Queen side he should have sat and waited
with the knight on d4 by the way you see
that beautiful blockade we talked about
this some times before all this happened
yeah the night sitting on d4 beautiful
blockading piece oh no nothing to do
about it but if you only are blockading
the pawn you're not attacking it so who
cares that's not a problem
you've got to the pawn on d5 but that's
not what I needed he simply started
making active moves and ruined his own
position well the blockade a knight
suddenly became an attack is not worried
about the D pawn anymore he's got a
target I was a little bit surprised by
the move Bishop e2 I thought that with
move rook a three blacks eyeballing an
opportunity to try to attack the part on
III I thought that rook to d1 is for
example rip D 193 bishop
I like they should be typic it's a
tactical solution B - you can't play
Knight f5 if I can
let's do it because I think you just
push beep on baby just push him baby is
that 3 B 6 root P 7 root C 7 I don't
care about my pond yeah no this is the
pond on e30 part of the games not part
of the game that's irrelevant
yeah you got your material back but I'm
queen this is crushing oh boy oh boy oh
boy okay so that's what it's all about
you're just going to play after the move
Bishop e2 you're just gonna play take a
look at these positions normally I see
okay where's blacks fight right Black
has this counter play and okay the
b-pawn I'll protect the b-pawn with this
but right now I'm really how do I stop
this bomb yeah I'm not even thinking
about Connor playing blockades I'm
really thinking how do I just stop it
right I'm playing b5 b6 rooks e7 the
night it's really weird but the night
can't really come down to my it wants to
go to b6 this night wants to go to b6
and blockade this point exactly how do I
get it to b6 I can't be 4 is just
resigns I can't go down to pause no d4
takes 95 yeah yes to pause exactly so
how do I get it somewhere usable this
looks just terrible actually I take it
back Bishop b2 is actually just
wonderful mother because of b5 some BCH
and again you know you win your material
back but it's too late it is it's just
cleaning I just wanted to complete one
last thing you get the overworked piece
yeah that I guess the computer wanted me
to make a look well guys I mean I came
in somebody was predicting to victory
these guys don't
and look at this not a surprise not a
surprise what I'm gonna you're gonna see
a lot of these numbers and be shocked
the more this tournament goes on he has
a plus score I think it gets four
players in the field including Fabi
including probably where he has a 500
school wellö the last game was maybe
2012 or 2013
nevertheless Fabi was pretty good back
then as well this this young man he he
can play he can play and you could've
caught whatever you thought but this
tournament now is going to be a wild one
as he is put dropping a bomb we said
ding Lauren was in last excuse me a
niche Giri is about to join him in last
place as well and you talked about it
yeah sir
that they both in their last candidates
campaign neither one of them lost a
single game that's combined 28 games no
losses and informant in just 2 Affairs
here each saying you never can predict
that's why that's why you cannot predict
anything in these events and Wang Han
would be the sole leader after two who
would have said those words you two made
some money in Vegas on that yeah the
standard deviation here feels like 6 or
something off the chart I mean cosmic
numbers the kind of is such a different
tournament that sure that the players
have it's not like anything license they
think they're great tournaments of
course but if you do badly the first
couple rounds of a Singh field you
figure okay I'm tired I played a lot of
tournaments maybe the next one will be
my tournament this one is the one that
you've been preparing for so hard here
we spent a month preparing for this it's
a career-defining event exactly yeah
psychologically it each blow is so much
tougher yeah and you get two in a row by
the way by the way you know you see that
prize money the 500 thousand years euros
nice surprise that five hundred thousand
euros is what they're splitting for this
event the winner of this don't forget
that I won the lottery
yeah right I am NOT gonna play the World
Championship where the prize money there
will be multiples
two million so right now I hear right
that's what I know at the moment is two
million so that means if I lose
the event I should be walking away with
what 800 grand hey is it dollars or even
euros but there abouts right so the
winner is these these boys are not
playing for that the 500 didn't think
about they know the first place it wins
the lottery right and so and and and by
the way they play this guy yeah you beat
him if you which is a tall order bites
up but if you beat him you go down as a
world champion in the history of our
great game and with an epic performance
it's going to take to defeat such a
champion as this one as you can see all
his numbers are off the charts and he's
arguing that and maybe he will one day
be called the greatest player of all
time so you get that opportunity to play
Magnus Carlsen for that much money on
the world stage your stock goes way up
Fabia's established himself as a king
well maybe now a prince looking and
waiting possibly because he played so
tough against Magnus and Magnus knows he
would indeed be a stiff challenge as
well so we know what they're playing for
this possibility and the amazing chance
to play against Magnus Carlsen and and
change their game also you know they'll
be stronger for theoretically because
they will have prepared for such a beast
so we know how much this is at stake
it's not just the 500k and so one thing
I before I like before I stop this is
I'm going crazy make a point about this
individual event we had five of these to
start the candidates process started
with Budapest 1950 I played five of
those they played Zurich in 1953
Amsterdam 1956 they then played in
Yugoslavia in 1959 and NTC to Curacao it
was one tournament and that tournament
decided who played at the world champion
right Carissa painted the waters a bit
because there was some potential for
collusion among the Russians Fischer
charged them where they coordinate
charge them with collusion but so they
changed it to match play and that match
play is was different yet to qualify to
get into match play right so now it was
top eight no law
top eight played matches against each
other now you jump to Montpellier in
1985 that you played in yes sir right
that event was all
or tournament but it wasn't the pressure
off these those first five and these
last four now this f1 it wasn't the same
pressure because it wasn't just about
first place right it was the four
players playing to you you play to get
in the top four so that you can then
play the matches which suckle of one two
then play Karpov who seed it into the
finals of the of the match play and then
you know Karpov beat him and played
Kasparov but there's a different kind of
mentality you guys played in an 85 right
right because it was top four right
that's a different pressure than only
one of us is gonna make it exactly and
this tournament is so tough I mean to
win on-demand is incredibly hard to win
an event like this and just like you say
we're playing for first right we're not
playing for second we don't want to play
to look good we have to play to become
Challenger and so you know fabbi today
you know he's playing the lowest rated
player in the field and he's really got
a win I mean I really want to say that
the pressure is there for him every High
Point is so crucial for rounds yes
that's a lot of rounds but you look at
the reading difference you look at the
fact that you're white 5 is out of
himself you need to create opportunities
for yourself in this kind of tournaments
he found one today he wanted to sharpen
the game he caught his opponent in a
line that probably he hadn't prepared
well it's not Bobby's main rapper car
he's not much of a default player which
is very difficult and by the way if you
look at the two games I mean this is
very very early days right but if you
look at the two games that fabbi played
today he's playing the most sharp lines
white or black he is not backing down
and he's basically saying you know I am
the most well prepared player in the
tournament no I don't know what is
happening to tingling and I'm sure
everybody's being affected by
circumstance right that boy Dean Loren
who had an unbelievable 20-19 as did
Magnus Carlsen yes you know King Loren
was just amazing I was a Magnus Carlsen
show and just done till the second half
way through say
[Music]
right exactly
yeah exactly so and Wow I mean and we're
looking at the last game to be played
again we've got two wins one draw in the
record book cause it looks like we're
gonna have a third when before we take a
break well yes sir before that let's
just say that this game will take a
while rumored this is a very classical
time control and the players have
reaching 40 which means each of them got
an extra 50 minutes so we encourage you
to give us a call here at the studio
right let's see and I think we do have a
caller just before we took a break we
got a call by the way we've just seen
the move Bishop e2 and initially now
release oh he did he did I was about to
say anisha is really settling in to the
fact that oh my word it's really really
bad he's a boss here 85 in the dark
square in it for the moment yeah you
just hope that somehow this night comes
and rescues you somehow as well with
Knight f5 to d6 just got word that we
didn't get the call we will have false
alarm will have cost later we'll take a
short break and we'll be right back with
you guys don't go anywhere
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen be surprised
be intrigued be delighted the world
chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015 SLU
partner with the same Lewis chess club
to start a top-tier collegiate chess
team on the very first year of the Peace
inception slough obtained second best
University at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back with round two of the
20/20 candidates with already two
decisive results out of three games my
Mira cabrona and Maxine Michelle McGrath
winning with the white pieces
respectively against Felix same cook and
Jamie Lee run which who see it's just
bottom off the table waiting to see if
I'm nice giri will also be there with a
goose egg after two rounds and suffering
it no question about it we have a tie
for first three players at one and a
half but one player wang hao is
eyeballing an opportunity to be the sole
leader after two rounds as he's nursing
a very nice extra pawn against on each
area you mentioned that was goose a what
a way to start defeating with the black
pieces his countryman Bingley ran from
the worst position exactly and he
admitted it as much I'm just finding
every resource in the in the situation
and now against on each gear he got a
nice pleasant position from the opening
or just felt like he outplayed him and
you wanted to break out he just didn't
want to be corralled he wanted to go out
and find that Conor play backfire did
boomer off and right now did it ever he
I mean this is like a dream position for
white in terms of an isolated queen pawn
it's no longer an isolated clean this is
a story change yeah the stories about
this be part exactly an extra an extra
pawn supported magnificently by this
Bishop on e to black is doing is very
level best to keep a block eighties just
played the move rook b6 now eventually
as why you want to play moves like rook
c7 and rook d7 I think you just start
with a move like rook c5 just preparing
this eventualities of making more more
progress as a vegetal do to protect your
pumps or to do things slowly build
things up I like a patient
way of going I'm an idiot rook c7 I'm a
dream kind of guy
yes rusi sovereign is the first thing I
think but I'm wondering is not a5
something that I'm think
it's just too much a little bit too much
to allow well this that remember the the
obvious lines where you know our be pond
was doing horrible things and just
blowing the game open in this case
because he hasn't even captured on e3
yet he gets to corral the pawns that
rook behind the pond it's a very
important concept in any kind of an game
rooks behind the pond you allowed that
we're coming to c3 surround your
partner's then we go to the fun because
rusi salmon doesn't work right because
neither five and I'm running into
trouble right this is where I play a lot
of iron games and I consider myself a
pretty decent end game player right
compared to other four and I like it
it's strategically horrible move e5
square yeah we can your pawn but it has
this specific point which is to keep
this knee knight dead exactly the knight
can't move to f5 you can't move to d5 if
it retreats then I have rook c6 at all
at all points yeah
I agree normally speaking the movie for
it's the type of move you do for a very
very specific purpose because you are
taking a potential weakness the isolated
Queens pawn and you're and you're kind
of where you are you're splitting your
pawns the you you're giving yourself the
isolated problem but you're doing it
because you're keeping this night
completely bottled up
I like efore I just kind of like move
rook c5 a little bit better okay but
certain for we do have a phone call from
California please give us your name and
your question yeah my name is Carlos
Salazar hydrolyse welcome to our show
thank you thank you yeah I'm a big chess
fan and I follow most of the big
tournaments and I'm usually you know
okay was seeing drawers because I know
that at this level really hard to get a
win but I'm surprised to see so many
wins so far you guys think that this has
to do with
psychology is chess in this competition
Carlos thank you for the question
because yes we are seeing what I would
call an extremely high level of decisive
games very early in the tournament I
think things kind of get settled down I
mean normally speaking at you know this
type of a tournament it's such a high
level people are coming in a full of
energy vim and vigor they really really
want to show their very best at the
start and there's nerves and butterflies
and what-have-you
this number of decisive games is
psychological I do you because if you
compare it to any kind of an elite
tournament that you see on the grand
chest or you know you don't have so many
I mean what's the sync though cut maybe
25% over the course of six years or
whatever it's right and you know that
Wow right now many decisive games after
two rounds well there is one negating
factor for sure there the fact that
there is a sub 2700 player or just on
the cusp of 2,700 player in the
tournament reminds you of other elite
tournaments of that nature most notably
Tata Steel right this is not a same
field cup the same field cup will
feature top eight player top ten players
in the world and you'll see tons of
draws this one has a bit of a spread you
in the same field Cup you don't see a
hundred and fifty rating points spread
between first and last and that usually
brings out the beasts and that's that by
itself usually gets people who will
answer you thinking that guy I've got a
beat and their attitude is always one
game should be decisive I don't want to
be the guy who only draws him I want to
be the guy who beats him so I think oh
does shift the the border a little bit
to be sure and it may be significantly
so but also we should add you're right
about the psychology ding Lauren doesn't
lose two games in a row he went off a
hundred games would know that with no
losses much less to go back-to-back with
losses this just doesn't happen to this
guy so there's something wrong going on
with England
the moment we heard some reasons from
Fabi and Winehouse when he was
interviewed yesterday also seem to put a
put a possible excuse for his countrymen
in being a trying time in general so we
are we're seeing something early happen
I think it's very easy to imagine that
this settles down right now we begin to
see more normalcy withdraws not two wins
everyday or maybe even three wins every
day right it's just very very unusual
and again I think that's very wise
Maurice you you were talking some
history about these candidates
tournaments and plus three before the
event if somebody had said to you what's
going to tie for first you're saying
plus three autumn a three yeah but
you're saying that because of Carole's
presence that might require a little bit
more it might move up just a bit like
three point two or something like that
more than that I think more than that
probably wanted with plus four when he
wanted again plus three usually wins
this tournament and plus three would
have won it when he won because he the
closest person was it plus two but the
reality is the if somebody like Bobby
says listen I'm gonna take this point
right here this is a point usually five
II couldn't count on points think about
that you can't you can't look at anybody
in a normal candidate field and say he's
a point he's a point okay me he might be
able Ono you've got eight gangsters
right you got criminals assassins
everywhere every one of them you think
if I play this guy five games and the
score is two and a half two and a half
that's okay that's a good result yeah
and everybody's like that everybody so
you're looking around like where am I
getting points from so plus three is the
majestic results it's a really awesome
result you're gonna gain rating points
maybe Magnus might not gain even Magnus
Gates at plus three yeah so when you got
put somebody in the field where
everybody no no no this guy if I play in
five games I'm doing better than fifty
percent right and that's hero and so now
that shifts it a bit because anybody who
beats him says I told you I got
him you better beat him because I got
him and that's my point and now I'm
going to look for the rest of the points
through you guys and I think that's
what's gonna change the dynamic here is
having a player who just simply make
makes it makes it weird I mean he is
literally separated from my niche by 60
rating this is laughter own this is
librarians update right he was even more
than this Wow right before the round so
you imagine somebody who was 50 60 70
radio 2044 now 20s Pappy Bobby right
jumped three right Bobby this is not
totally live this was after this was
after round one I knew exactly so coming
into today
coming into today this and that's not
the key Rogaine a rating point and a
niche has dropped because of his loss so
the separation was broader than this
coming in that bottom of the just it
just affects you psychologically that's
right a lot of people say they'd like to
see a random wild card and even if that
person is the victim just just throw
them in there we need some fresh meat
for the players and they they're gonna
beat up on him because it just gives
more flavor to the tournament not fair
to your 26 90s and the sweaty 700 is
like really I gotta be the one but
that's the reality these guys at the top
are pure sharks like Natural Born
Killers and you give them somebody that
could be a victim they're gonna go after
him yeah just a small detail there don't
they learned they didn't lose that much
rating on his forget heroes $27.99
coming in into today's round he's
dropped 227 a 94 or 99 but he's he's
dropped precipitously he's already in
the tournament you can count on every
loss is going to be 5 but in his case a
little bit more than more because he's
2,800 so much higher right Wang Hao Wang
Yao was gained so much that if he wins
today he's gonna be number eight in the
world but not only that numbers gonna be
number eight he's going to be this much
from numbers seven and six is it heard
there because right there as Aronian was
maybe point would be 0.6 ahead of him
another victory will put him at number
five on the planet well right behind an
all-time perfect about that
on the planet another victory actually
puts them above nipple if that photos
all right if nipple doesn't keep the
number four in the world by the way and
if he wins and ding the ring keeps
losing we can see wang hao is number
three in the world now maybe the same I
mean it's like wow that is quite a bit
of a difference between ding there and
an echo there are 20 points there but
thank you to Carlos for the question
about the winds and Yahoo situation
we're very very strange
psychologically what's going on in the
terminal I think we can see more dross
though we're gonna have to see like four
rounds of you know rounds of draws like
four players yeah we should see that
talked about an explosive start though
we really we kind of brush it but it is
a big deal the players are not
comfortable they're just not comfortable
no this is not the tournament where you
go in you prepare their their seconds
are there everything is going smoothly
you're there to play the best chess you
can the truth is players game into
Russia with difficulties they don't know
what their flights were sometimes
there's some flights were canceled they
don't know that Warren teen dealer and
spent two weeks in the outskirts of
Moscow it's in quarantine you don't want
to be in quite fresh air go to a
restaurant a nice walk on the boulevard
yeah wow that is not even with the
seconds there he wasn't able to code it
I mean all kinds of things are
surrounding the tournament and they make
it weird
exactly when weirdness happens weirdness
on the chess board as well yeah it is a
very unusual set of as circumstances but
take a phone call a phone call from
Marilyn again please tell us your name
and your question hi my name is Amir
Amir and I'm pulling from Maryland great
show great commentary I really enjoy
watching you guys
my question is I think I was back in the
1970s during the matches of Karpov and
Kasparov that a model like a drawing
with when you are black you strive for a
draw but when you are white you you
strive for a win and it seems to me that
it's like lacking ambition with with
black I just wanted to know why did they
start that model thank you very much for
the question of course if you go back
into the 1800s and Romantic era of chess
black white no decisive game just kept
going I mean there was the advance of
the opening theory where white was given
an edge and you said white has the first
movie and he gets a chance to create in
and they should have been gained the
advantage I remember my very first
Olympiad in Malta in 1980 ma our dear
friend pal Benko recently passed away
was our team captain and PAL bancos
formula for success was very simple draw
black win with white and it wasn't
really win with white it was like
pressure your opponent you know make
them on the defensive and that was 1980
and from that point period forwards I
was watching these World Championship
matches and Kasparov Karpov and carpa
Korchnoi matches and then kramnik it was
always the same people were trying to
break down the opponent when they were
white and just hold the position from
the right so I mean it's a long it's
it's decades that's the way it's been in
the world of chess and in today's world
of chess
when Fabiano sits down with the black
pieces like he did yesterday he's not
just comfortably sitting back saying oh
I should draw today well the ideal for
every chess player is to get a position
in which you have chances right but
you're not excessively risking and when
you are on the second side with black
it's very difficult
those positions there are only a certain
limited amount of openings and positions
that you can get where you yes you get a
playable position right but the level of
risk is acceptable most of the time with
white if you have a little bit of a risk
that extra move gives you the edge to
risk and not be completely out of your
mind with that risk with black a lot of
the times when you risk it's just really
really going for it for example
something like the Kings Indian yeah
very ambitious right but as soon as you
play the Kings Indian oh man there's no
turning back that's it you are risking
so much weight and in these kind of
matches in this kind of tournaments the
unnecessary risk can be punished very
severely exactly I mean you look at the
record of a lot of these risky openings
they don't have a Creed record not at
the top right Kings Indian ponies one of
the openings that seems double-edged but
worth the risk is the Sicilian business
iliyan has whole held up for years
because of that both the Niner find this
fashion cuff I've been used to
tremendous effect recently and
throughout history because it provides
black not only with a playable and good
position but balance right chances as
well jump in here Maurice well let me
say to me they're two two things that
had a seismic effect on the attitude of
the black pieces nowadays before yeah
sir if we go back in the day having
black was just like oh my god I got what
is it guy gonna play this is gonna be
tough should I just try to be solid like
a coward car like yourself you want to
play something shark White's thinking
I'm hacking away I got white I'm
supposed to hack away right but what
happened first of all there was a guy
named Kramnik who looked at despair over
and said I know you're you're a killer
but I'm gonna put a defense up against
you and you're gonna buck your head into
this defense and you're not gonna solve
it and that was the bird layin right and
suddenly players had a refuge they could
go somewhere to hide and everything was
okay ish basically very hard to beat and
we saw just draw up on draw upon draw so
now black felt a bit safer but then the
next thing that happened that was
critical
huge and this happened simultaneously
was the advent of the engines and the
engines these days
they you got black you say oh I can I
can pretty much equalize I can I can't
get playable positions it used to be
that white would sack a pawn for the
initiative like back in carros de bring
no problems go for it nowadays you're
not giving up that pawn like no no I'm
not just giving up a pawn for the
initiative because people can defend so
well now again because of Injuns
practicing with them and also they know
black is ok there's some line that says
black is ok no matter how sharp your
line looked so now white is actually on
the back foot not like you used to be
where you're like I'm hacking away now
you're looking for stuff to do and even
Wesley once said that when he made this
drawer who did he make a draw against
his father it was Bobby and he's like
and he said well why did you play to
this and he says you tell me you know so
these days because black is okay black
feels a lot more comfortable because
they can prep with the engines they're
gonna be fine I don't have to play risky
I can just be okay and in the meantime
with white and I'm gonna struggle just
to find some kind of creative play way
to play and they're happy when they see
an active position you're probably saved
himself now I was happy today it was
some life in this position sharp I could
play this position and let's hope the
guy makes a mistake and even though he
didn't know it by the way even though he
wasn't well prepared he got the kind of
position he wanted and there was his
victory I have the experience of being a
very hockey player and comes to opening
repertoire I grew up in the open system
ok and in the open system of chess you
have to win like why did the swiss
german you got a score 90% to get a
price i remember i want to tournament
with grab tons of grandmasters the US
Open and I want it giving up two draws
right yeah like that's how you win it
and the guy below me had only gave up
three draws lotta games so my opening
repertoire is fill of like Alec kinds
and we're Sicilian and goes which I mean
when you analyze this seriously like you
actually make a serious analysis on this
and for example it was a problem for me
coming into the US Championship right
when I played Cara Nakamura even
Alexandra let me show you know I mean
they're really solid guy he saw that you
you play this kind of hockey stuff
they'll just grab you and torture you
yeah they know it in and out and they
know where the weaknesses of this
omitted Clark yeah and suddenly when I
started really working on some open
especially when I started working with
Fabi yeah I looked at some openings with
black and it's like oh why not just not
be worse yeah I'm the opening every time
right right right so why not be equal it
just seems so much better and that's
kind of what happens in the world of
chess right now black why decides why
should I be worse
let's just be equal right instead of you
know having a terrible position from the
opening but again without risk you you
you were warped by your experience
whereas a open Swiss player where you
have to win black white green pieces
doesn't matter you got to win you're
taking a lot of risk a lot of risk and
that was kind of where you grow up from
like I didn't have a the proper let's
say just ran the classical Chester you
know I was never told look you have to
learn a 45 is black because you will at
some point play it it's in your life and
that was kind of like the Soviet style
of chess when I went in the 1980s to
Europe and I again like yourself I was
warped with this open style of play
where I was taking excessive risk perk
defense rat defense whatever you want to
call them and I saw the Zoltan Wrigley's
of the world keeping night of 3G cattle
lands and just playing plus one yeah for
the whole tournament it was like plus
one didn't do it make any money and by
the way yes yeah I knew you grew up in
in the u.s. in a Great Northwest
Northwest Seattle
having a tough time right now it's best
to those great folks in Seattle and I
know you know you played a lot of blitz
and all that but I grew up in Brooklyn
yeah okay right plus one baby and you
play sharp with boat color as you play
Wow and when I went to Europe for the
first time that's exactly what happened
guys were playing these ultra solid
positions like what's going on what's
this and man I took that first trip I
took it on the chin because I wanted to
keep it wild and busy in these guys we
used to no no no you big classical and
shut that thing down and you know you
you know there's only so much risk you
can you can do in order to get rewarded
and the risk/reward formula was not
working when you play these sharp hockey
openings okay we do have one more phone
call but I did want to get into the game
a little bit but first let's take the
phone call and as we get back to y'all
caller from Ohio would I press it stuck
in homework okay hello welcome to our
show your name and question please hi my
name is Connor I'm from Canton Ohio and
my question is while I was watching the
show today I was doing some ap United
States history homework and while
reading they talked about the Spanish
flu that occurred a hundred years ago
and talked about how it devastated the
economy so from a chess perspective how
do you guys think you know the current
pandemic going on how do you think it's
going to you know change our views
towards the future of chess and when we
look back on you know this time now in
the future you know what do you think is
going to happen what are the what-ifs
that are going to you know spring up as
a result of that Wow thank you for the
question I'll just take a quick crack at
it because I know that you'll want to
jump in here alejandro first of all
let's boldly state the obvious you've
just been invited to the US Championship
which has been postponed and tournaments
across the world not just these
championships but did the Grand Cay
tournament the Icelandic open I mean
which is a great tournament everybody
looks forward to so many tournaments
being canceled it's just it's having an
enormous ripple impact
yeah this question let's be clear is
very narrowly about chess yeah what
happens in the chess world this will
have huge impacts and many other kids
but specifically about the chess world
it's always very harmful to us because
we're kind of the first things to go we
rely on sponsors and when the economy
goes down sponsorship goes way down and
said let's just get cancelled right even
tournaments with great tradition like
lean ours mm-hmm for example for example
talk to Steve's a little wobbly we have
we because they rely on profits if its
profits are not there there's no money
for sponsorship its we rely on a lot of
them it doesn't really affect us that
much that we have a lot of things
postponed okay Reykjavik doesn't get
done this year they can skip a year it
won't change the chess world it's a pity
yeah a lot of chess players you know
would like to play it would like to play
it but we have some problems there but
the sponsorship for a lot of events
might just evaporate on the other hand
what a chess player is doing for their
online there a lot of them are lying I
love it already like I already have
moved to online teaching but those that
rely on Bundesliga to make a living it's
the European leagues and a lot of
players are like that they rely on
playing chess for a living they rely on
traveling they live basically paycheck
to paycheck playing leagues and
tournament to tournament and those
leagues just don't exist yeah ballistic
has been cancelled the foreign CL the
one in England has been cancelled all of
them have been either cancelled or
postponed right so right now for a lot
of professionals there is no job right
and the professional chess League online
sponsored by chess calm they have the
final four yeah in Norway and everybody
was looking forward to quite a party in
Norway I have my ticket book I know it's
terrible jump in here Maurice let's take
an historical perspective the young
man's question is a great one I'm a
student I consider myself a student of
history and yes indeed this is going to
affect chess but let's go broader than
just this one event or even even a
Spanish Flu think about the world wars
when the world wars to play
for years chess events were canceled all
around the world the world war one world
war two Paul Kerry's known as the
eternal second he won Avro in 1938 that
qualified him to play against one
alexandr hekkub
he's a chance to become the world
champion right and boom a cancellation
as all heck broke loose in Europe and
that he never got that chance Alexander
I can't eyes during the war
and then they had to play this
tournament the match tournament in
Moscow I believe it was with Bob Vinick
Kerry's got to play there as well but
that was already 10 years later he could
have been at the peak of his powers okay
he was still very strong when they
played the match tournament after the
war but he ended up coming in second in
that one then he played in Budapest
didn't come in he came in outside of the
top two and then he came in second for
events in a row tie for second or second
in the next four candidates never got
his shot so imagine that you're a player
you're at the potential peak of your
powers and now you have to stop and with
some big events so the world wars we did
see this example chess events tops all
over the world as well what happened
though after that chess recovered chess
remains an eternal light in our world as
part of world to culture 1,500 years of
it it continues to draw new young fans
as your self caller it will survive
beyond this we will all will make it
after this and chess will make it after
this as well it's just going to take
some time as the world shakes out a
particular issue as the world does
problems happen problems arise even big
ones like this one the world has seen
before and we all have to just be strong
and deal with it and don't worry the
game will be back Thank You Maurice for
that let's jump into the chess game okay
he left it here and he we we had seen
the move b5 rip to b6 and we talked
about this move a little but trying to
blockade on the dark squares dealing
with this problem
runaway pawn before it really becomes a
criminal be six and we don't think it
immediately is just unstoppable
exactly so rook b6 and this was a little
bit of a crafty move rook as a d1 great
patience yeah
keeping the knight anchored I guess I
want to put it like that way looking at
six like okay bring your king to e6 it
will be safe in the center of the board
and it will defend the pawn on d5 and
release the knight roopd - okay I see I
do too
I like that move a lot I I like
strategic concepts as simple as as the
following I really do this I do this
very consciously what is my opponent's
best guy yeah you know what's his
all-starr oh I get it
this rook on a3 is the all-star for my
opponent well what I've got to do is
I've got to get rid of that all-star and
I see this move and I sit there saying
to myself oh this move sets up for rook
a to and on a good day the rook can come
to a6 and hit the block a derp on a b6
oh I see that move is a nice move that's
a little bit of a surprises he's setting
up for e4 I think he's setting up for
efore I also think when I see a lot of
these positions it just keeps your
options open
we're going to probably was this idea
but it's something that you probably
don't have to play now well you give
yourself that space to do it when you
need it yeah this is a lot of I think
grandmasters do all the time they put
their pieces where the threat they might
execute doesn't work right now right but
maybe down the line right it might
because situation has changed
it helps you yeah and I think that route
d2 is just such a useful move in that
scenario because rotate to something
that you might always think about from
now and in the future and I like the
fact that he takes his time plays Bishop
d3 he could even have thought of Bishop
d3 thinking e2 then broke a to something
very slow because he also sleeps box
position and he thinks how is he going
to improve right are you kind of running
out of ideas here right now I don't need
7 doesn't have anywhere to go right the
king if it comes into the center I'm
gonna hit it with a floor and suddenly
it's gonna have a barrage of checks so
he's thinking it slow is taking his
strides he's finally broken with E for
so finally he plays the movie four so
you see the move rook d2 Bishop d3 is
this kind of flexible I think all your
options open you haven't committed
yourself to anything and by the way once
you once black has put his knight
I don't know on the b6 square or right
now like on c8 the night on the edge I
break in the Sun exactly now they very
much know that you've passively placed
your knight now let's talk about efore
you are getting rid of a potential
weakness right I mean let's say teh okay
and from blacks point of view blacks
thinking okay well I mean I'm doing my
best to hang on I do have a blockade and
I just got rid of a potential weakness
d5 yes give me you know like black is
dreaming I don't know give me a chance
to play Knight d6 and maybe I can keep
it up how does how should white in your
view continue well there's a couple of
moves that kind of jump at me I look at
the King on f6 I think it's a bit of a
weakness I'm trying to figure out if
there's a tactical way to exploit it
like if you could play rook c6
[Music]
chancellor for in some variations okay
so so I'm looking at all these kind of
ideas I'm trying to improve my rooks
okay the first move that I think of is
route BC - does that move win rook the C
- does that move for win yeah then
because I have to analyze Knight a7 does
this actually work for me and as you're
looking at rook CC I'm looking at rook
c6 does this work so I spent a little
bit of time calculating this move right
because if c6 works well that's the end
of the game exactly so all these kind of
things I start to look at the other
thing I would look at is to just
restrain my opponent I know that his
idea is gonna be either 97 or 96 like
try to find something against them we're
not really sure what to do right now
because Bishop c6 which is one of
another kind of widget by the way a you
know you talk about the King on f6 is
being a problem piece maybe a tactical
target on a good day you get to play
rook to d7 that's yeah so the bishop c6
kind of
puts the rook on d6 yeah and a little
cage there
so you see Bishop c6 you see rook c2 as
options you are talking about activating
the rooks rook d7 come into your mind
yeah rookie salmon definitely comes into
my mind because no neither nation would
feel a little bit uncomfortable I still
think that I move like rookie sand I
would have to calculate because for
example King e6 and I have to find an
actual position for this rook oh but
then it really works nicely if the guy
walks into because then you're that you
were mentioning the king could become a
time target ready to and you know like
looky looky there real nice open
highways for whites rooks the only issue
I see for a while now is that every move
is something that's the problem that's
the problem sometimes you just want one
clear path clarity here I don't see a
clear path I just figure I should have
keep improving right and I don't see a
way to rip the blockade any time soon
I'm just going to improve improve until
black can't hold yeah you break a
Maurice jump in here with the chess
engines thought on how you how you do it
by the way the chess engine is giving
nothing to crack the position ok several
moves looks like this position stays
pretty stable for a while that's giving
white a huge edge almost a to pawn edge
but not finding a sequence that said
this is how we crack it and even a
sequence that says this is how you
improve it to a point where you say yeah
and now it's going to be falling apart
pretty soon right and that to me what
that says is it's an interesting
situation the one advantage what he does
have is this pawn sitting on b5 he hopes
to get a secondary advantage like you
guys are bringing a rook to d7 and a
bishop on d5 making f7 work as another
events as well but it's very hard
because you can't let the dark square
blockade
my feeling is in this kind of position
the trick for white is to make sure to
put enough pressure so that the other
guy screws up and I know you don't want
to rely on the screw up but a lot of
chess is patience patience patience and
more patience more pressure I'm the one
who was better you're the one who's
defending you
to defend forever ever ever and by the
way who played a long game yesterday
suffered for a long long time
and ended up losing the game in the end
punished he thought maybe he could have
made a draw
yeah a nice giri and that's a part of it
as Urich if you are his opponent you're
like I know you're tired from yesterday
right it was a really bad result you
probably went home
you thought let me come back and fight
maybe make a drawing and you can be okay
no I'm gonna make you suffer the same
way you're worse you have to defend you
might be equal there might be miracle
drawing variations that you think are
going to happen but I'm gonna make you
suffer and suffer and suffer and that's
what professional players do and I think
that's what anisha's in for and we do
have a move by the way no well you were
saying that you were looking to activate
your rooks and you were looking at a
rook c2 to c6 with a check and I like
this move to from the point of view I've
got Bishop d5 it all comes to the
calculation of rook a seven-story
another big plus for one cow is that the
further traits we have the easier is
conversion it doesn't matter what you
trade at this point right I mean if it's
the bishop for the night and you've
already traded a couple rooks and your
rook on b2 stays alive well then you
just walk your King just King Bishop
against Knight trivial right for your
conversion the spawns on h v g6 and f7
are such easy targets you the knight
can't possibly hold upon them b5 and
defend the King side what alejandra
means right there by the way everybody
is that because White has a light square
bishop and all the black spots on the
King side they become constant targets
for the end of the game right for
example rookie said what do you do about
rooks III read about the c3 yeah okay
okay I'll bite yeah Bishop d6 continued
bishop I can't play Bishop c6 sorry
there's a tactic right over c6 so you
can so no I only played Bishop d5
because I can
d6 I thought Bishop c6 oh yeah okay -
okay so now okay - no but if you take us
back c5 Monday yeah the five attacks the
rook rook even King you five sorry no
this is I can trade and take this and
then come back and yeah it's just a drug
because I can take on a six take on any
six takes on the funny seven sorry okay
nice okay rook takes d5 I wanted to 87
rook a five rook takes our bikinis and I
can't defend the a pawn nice okay very
good
let's not allow the knight on these six
with the temple I only play this because
I thought bishop c64 sunday on top but
apparently it isn't by the way can i
play Ruby 7 yeah I'm gonna go into the
line just I just want to chose one thing
because you guys were talking about the
strength of the light squares right
White has that but and bishops are
incredibly powerful pieces but the main
weakness of the bishop is it's a 32
square piece right it can't control the
opposite color I'm not talking to you
guys now I'm talking the guys out and
sure in uh in TV land the point is your
Bishop is much more flexible than the
knight much more faster maybe
flexibilities in other word speedier
right it can just jet up and down the
board but it's stuck on one color and
when that happens the enemy forces can
often lift themselves off that color
complex as you see here it's not it's
not a mystery or magic why all of blacks
pieces gravitated to dark squares and
created some impotence for this Bishop
and his knight on a dark square attacks
a light square so this became a bit
trickier for white to convert and that
was the difficulty here although it
looked optically really good
suddenly it changes you go wait a minute
I it's not so easy I can't do it so
easily so that's the challenge your face
as you try to break down that's a
challenge he's facing as he tries to
bring down this position so now rook c3
back to here let's trade I'm kind of
wonder 7b7 look let's get rid of some
pieces you and that's that lifts the
blockade for sure so that's a good point
I think you want to go to b6 right yeah
I know how you're planning on stopping
my pawn if I just move to either d5 or
even a 44 looks completely winning
before here just
yeah okay I possibly take on e4 yes we
like that ending so rugby so root b7
but it seems here it's another position
of slowly improve I don't know I'll
bring my king I'll play rugby
- something like that's king - seems
like a move we're okay so you want to do
this all right so he's gonna bring his
king over and then I'll play something
like King D - I'm not afraid of 94 why
am I afraid of 94 what's good the bishop
will attack yeah so I have to be a
little bit careful I probably have to
bring my bishop back first or something
like this yeah so now your bishop is
nice and Titus I'm tired right they're
not taking you to uh play route C -
again I'm not really afraid of
exchanging I'll keep the fun always
again the night on b6 is great locator
but it's also a soft side down and then
you've got to start to turn your
attention to the Kings side and maybe
that f7 is the h5 to worry about is that
if you do take F and G that's gonna be a
draw you I have two elite a chief one
goodness is the Ross Bishop this against
this right if you can get rid of this
one yeah if I can get rid of a lot to
get rid of this and give up your piece
and get trade off rooks and be left with
a Bishop and pawn with the wrong color I
think that's too much for him to ask but
maybe that's the key maybe the core
point is trading off a pair of rooks
particularly the blockading rook and
then trying still a squeeze it's still a
ways to go but it's looking like some
progress and I think when he played this
move rook d7 I think that's his main
point his main point is to play rook b7
as a big threat because now now that's
the case that means if Knight d6 is then
can you play like this and a bishop c6
rook c3 Knight a game but suddenly the
knight is hanging so that is the problem
right you can't get that in in time so
that's why you had to play this rook
move first trying to time it out so
route b7 that that sounds like the
the idea that makes blacks position much
worse which is kind of funny when the
rooks were double I'm the second rank
and there was a bishop on d3 I was
thinking of trading a rook right but I
wanted to trade the rook on a3 not the
real god b6 I was thinking like Brooke
on b6 is a nice blockade or the
opportunity you do trade I'd work on a3
but it's it's just so active that it's
difficult to catch it like if we just go
back to the point position where he
played the movie for yeah so this is
where efore and this is where I thought
the move rook d2 and I like the idea of
king e2 which you had mentioned as well
can you - Brooke C - I'm gonna be
threatening at some point rook a - and I
agree with you that it looks more
logical to trade that's why that guy
than the one on be safe right so well
just a different approach but one of the
things that you have said Alejandro that
really echoed it's it sort of like any
kind of endgame a rook and pawn endgame
a Bishop versus Knight endgame a rook
and Bishop versus night where are you
keeping the b5 pond of course yeah makes
it really easy and you're just looking
for a path that makes it easy and
disrupt e7 to b7 loosely three on the
board there wasn't too many choices
action or anisha and rook c3 looks like
a very logical move and now we're more
or less settled that Bishop d5 96 I mean
it felt like I didn't really want to
give up on this line because it almost
looks like this gotta be something that
works for white look at those dark
squares I know that looks like checkers
right wait for black at least but this
move rook b7 looks to be the money move
Maurice just eliminate that guy and play
rook and Bishop versus rook and Knight
with the extra pawn the more you trade
the better for you exponent in this case
it looks like well positionally founded
to play such a move and it's going to be
difficult a very difficult defense
because you're stuck
basically you'll be functioning a piece
down if white ever
coordinates right because your
blockading you say I got the core in the
blockade but again it's that other side
of the board so if we see this happen
this position yet we're trading here
right and putting this move is right if
you have to play this move the night
looks really cool in that Square it does
blockading this pawn you can never
really doesn't look like it easily
ejected me but why it's gonna start
thinking about the other side and why
it's gonna play this slowly as we said
and sooner or later it's this night
you're always as black you're always
looking over at the night cuz you know
white has some scheme to bring the rook
over and yeah you know that's always
there that white is looking for and
white will submit the advantage of this
pawn on this on that square that extra
part of your knight will just be stuck
so then I mean even I see freewheeling
move the bishop get the rook around
somehow and just start torturing the guy
and that's gonna be continuous a
continuous theme sooner or later is also
going to be this problem sooner or later
and sooner or later it's also gonna be
this problem right because if you trade
pawn takes like this kind of trade later
is gonna be suggesting this which is
gonna freeze this King so they're gonna
be suck the board's gonna get wider
which Knights hate this night all the
way over here can't help out the boys
are going to get wider and wider and
sooner or later is gonna be back to this
barn again so there's so many issues to
deal with that yeah something's gonna
land and we got the time issue as well
so I think Geary is hoping that buying
out gets himself into time pressure and
blunders makes an error as he defends
tenaciously because he knows this
position should be lost right well thank
you for that Maurice as we take another
short break I just wanted to give a
shout out to our colleagues who he fund
yeah and miss panko are doing Chinese
broadcast and they had a
million a million people watching and I
just I just think that that is just so
cool well if you speak Mandarin you
rejoin them for now let's take a small
break we'll be right back as we see if
speaking of Chinese players again want
I'll convert and become the sole leader
of the tournament
don't go anywhere this is still ongoing
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health and strength it's the sound
of compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities it sounds
like life and it's what you hear when
you really listen be surprised be
intrigued be delighted the world chess
Hall of Fame in st. Louis is nothing
you'd expect and everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015 SLU
partner with the same Lewis chess club
to start a top-tier collegiate trustee
on the very first year of the Peace
inception slough obtain second best
University at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back we do have two results
that were decisive today as we saw the
game off Fabiano karana crushing hero
Alex ANCA but even worse was this
Smackdown that MV l gave Tingler and
clearly not informed here in the
candidates to start off his tournament
meanwhile the Russian derby between
alexandra district with the black pieces
well he helped pretty comfortably in the
black side of a Berlin against
Yanukovych II a game that was a little
bit strange but we can't really say that
either side had a a great advantage at
any point exactly two decisive games out
of the 3-1 game offending Lang how we
see that three players are tied for
first of the moment the White House is
hoping to leapfrog all of them if he can
win and convert the extra pot yeah but
before that we do have a shout out at us
we do have a birthday in the building
the one and only Ben Simon big dick and
you guys might not be familiar with Ben
Simon but here the Chess Club we know
him we'd love him dearly
he's been around for ever since before
the Chess Club started and then was the
first guy who was recording my chess
classes whenever I did a lecture I was
the Grandmaster and resident here at the
club he set up the whole situation and I
think he's uploaded over a thousand
videos yeah lectures that have been here
at the club so if you've enjoyed our
videos any of the opening tracks opening
traps a guy why that's the guy that's
the guy that makes it happen so the
shout out to Ben who's turning 16 I can
[Laughter]
and what do you got first Murray's in
the game big time news absolutely
because now the Smoot King is moved to
e5 and if you are black you're thinking
okay I've got the blockade on b6 I've
got the active work on c3 my king is
getting active looks like some stuffs
happening not so much this B pawn is
still on the board and in fact you're
not going to get that much activity
because of this move rookie 2 has
nothing
it is yet but this would be a very
difficult move it'sa me in fact its way
look to d2 I'm not gonna make too much
of a point about it but this one though
rookie 2 was quite strong the reason is
note this line came to d4 the move
Bishop to c6 now what do we like about
this move we got nothing we're not
worried about this side anymore again we
said your night and the night is
basically a pawn it's dealing with the
pawn sir your knight is just a pawn so
while it's busy doing that look at all
these yummies on the other side of the
board the weakness and your king that
was defending it with the King on f6 is
now sitting on d4 pseudo activity but
not doing anything whatsoever here the
pawns are just now turning into victims
this would have been a very powerful
move rook to e2 in pretty much all lines
instead he put work to d2 preventing an
activity that he probably wanted to see
happen in the game is not it's not that
it's completely throwing away his
advantage but it wouldn't have been as
crispy as the move rook to e2 I'll point
out that rook to e2 would have chased
the King back you say what if the King
just backs up when I suddenly looked to
see two shows up on the board and this
one you did not want to see because rook
c6 is coming with effect you have to
trade off this piece and now the night
as we said there's a big pond and the
problem of this particularly this H pawn
on the board the board is too wide for
the knight to deal with this king is
coming soon this bishop is going to tie
you down and you're not defending this
position so dad looks like he missed a
real opportunity with rook to e2 did
Wang Hao look to d2 is going to make it
a little bit more challenging he's still
there
with a good chance to win but look like
he missed that real shot and as we said
the clock matters because he's currently
on move 53 he has 7 moves to make with
only 755 left to go he's the one with
the advantage of course but don't take
an advantage for granted we know in
chess it can't just slip away in a move
yes it could be equal there's one thing
I really don't like about the move
rookie to root 2 is very visual because
it forces things so I don't have to
think about general concepts either it
works or it doesn't the King goes
forward I go Bishop seasick
again I don't have to think about
general concept I was just munching your
ponds exactly the thing about I don't
like about root t2 is that subtly what
has no threat and Geary has quickly
playing the move Ruby t3 getting is real
better positioned behind them behind the
pond and we talked about this rook
behind the pond is such an important
concept because now in the weird
scenario that the knight is traded for
the bishop the second games aren't
winning anymore exactly the the they're
only winning when the rook is behind the
pawn no one is randomly somewhere and
with the bishop coming to c6 now my
roots behind the phone now my Knights
not a pawn right it's free it's free
yeah and she's not necessarily doing
that much throw this night your eyes
were specific specific what am i but the
night even on that squares looks a
little bit delicate you know Bishop d5
could happen at some moment but that
said you didn't want to release it from
prison no but I actually do challenge a
move here for white because after Bishop
c6 94 I don't know if there's a better
move there might be a better move but
Bishop d6 94 right what is your next
move okay let's start route black King
e6 and now I have a very serious threat
because 95 is a threat right and if you
go there and you still have now you have
repeated check I have a repeat I have to
throw and repeat your check it's not
sure exactly your kinks going somewhere
you guys know about those gotta go and
now let's say I go tonight I'm not sure
if ePHI for d6 because I see three it so
it looks so visual for some reason but
maybe I'm wrong yeah looking for yes but
let's say Knight d6 I'm not sure 96 95
how do you defend this pawn
oh that's a problem I bet I'm tying up
my pieces I'm not happy about whatever
is inside I mean everything is tied up
the rook is yelling and firing I'm gonna
have to crawl my king in fact I can't
even I move Knight laying that f5
well you tell me about Oh the e3 pawn
the game the b-pawn went okay you can go
upon hunting with Knight xg3 if you like
but I think the e3 squared oh wait wait
93 check doesn't yeah and then to check
in Brooke c6 yeah you still have a roof
d3 that miraculously saves you but
that's just a drop
no you don't want this you don't want
this we're not looking at miraculously
yeah Wow
okay rook d2 that soft move is real
culprit because six is now on the board
which is logical this is by the way the
engines hate Bishop c6 really and
because of the move Knight c4 suddenly
black is creating some issues bit of d3
stopping 9 c4 guarding a pawn is why the
engines wanted to do and that would you
see it you say yeah looks pretty good
that looks pretty good his rook d2 was
quite so two moves now route d2 and
Bishop c6 and like we said no we said
this suddenly it's a slip though you you
get the clock pressure when you're down
when you're worse
you need to cling to everything your
position might be worse might even be
lost but you need to Clint to whatever
you can and one thing is the clock
without question as a part of chess and
you look at the clock times in each goes
can I complicate a little bit sneak him
stop and think and maybe not play the
the precise karpova and move and it
looks as though his opponent has indeed
felt that pressure and didn't point
precisely and now he's by the way the
Meuse he's playing they don't look bad
number t2 and Bishop c6 they don't babby
six like like a bishop eh citing might
appear at any moment but the slight
imprecision and sudden activity of the
black pieces so mm you're never going to
get those things that you want and I'm
getting some things as well so Anish
suddenly there with a shout and I see
fire on the board you can imagine and
he's play Knight c4 yes it was no longer
a big fat pawn it's not
active piece this is turned into work if
if it's still winning right I'm a that's
the hardest thing and just to win
winning position somehow it'd be really
good for white but now I'm trying to
figure out a coordination between my
pieces because I am scared I mean as I
did say in rehearsal ninety-nine
hoppity-hop yeah this one on c4 is
currently going to go to t6 Turkey my
phone on b5 if the Kings not on e5 on b5
sorry
the King said on e5 the night itself
would go to e5 target's my bishop on c6
defends the partner seven it targets a
partner three is doing all these jobs
yeah that it didn't have it was a part
of be successful and now it looks like
like a knight for real yeah and this
real Knight and that Bishop on c6 just
defending doesn't look like it's doing
anything and that rook on b3 also
they're all very annoying in the last
two moves blacks gained a tremendous
amount of activity
how about f4 check for is necessary
because the King on e5 coordinates the
d6 square yeah and I don't want to see
the knight coming to the d6 where so I'm
thinking f5 check I'm gonna drive okay
just to boldly state the obvious don't
walk into the skewer there with so
you're gonna have to move the kingdom
and s4 plate and best move okay you go
King f6 and now maybe like rook t4 rook
t4 rook d7 I'm not sure I was thinking I
was yeah trying to I'm starting to think
of 93-94 if that's gonna be an issue
maybe that's not an issue 93 94 7 check
is on untappd 47 King e6 apparently the
strongest way to play in that moment
King e6
because again this idea of the 996 and I
thought the time for Bishop d5 exactly
you just sidestep Bishop d5 for the
moment the rook is hanging so I can't
move my bishop and this has become a lot
this this is now considered by the
engines to be a draw
Wow Wow that's this has been totally
frittered away this lot this move wrote
to d2 coupled with Bishop to c6 it's
just like he's going to kick himself
laying how when he realizes that he
could have played with rookie two
instead with the same idea but with the
riccati to complete see change in the
position Wow
and this this now Anish is feeling the
momentum going his favor and you know
what you know momentum counselor chest
Yoli right you know momentum counts
momentum I usually say momentum you know
as they're as good as your last move but
the psychology in chess is so important
that when you go from undead I can fight
now and the other guy feels it we talk
zero-sum the other guy feels the
difference in the swing of the game and
he starts to go from wait I had this
this was easy what's going on - stop
that psychological train from going in
that direction is very difficult we've
all done it
we've all had great positions where this
is this should be good yeah I'm gonna
suck then we get to play what happened
then you start thinking where did I mess
up right you got to stay focused but
your brain is going yeah did I did I
make an error and you start thinking
about everything but the chessboard and
your brain starts to get scattered so I
can tell you weighing out will kick
himself for having a beep on protecting
nice juicy part on b2 on b5 I had and
now he's thinking I didn't win this game
that he'll have a deflating effect if in
fact he doesn't win the game so he's got
to get his brain right and hope he can
find some chances to make a niche
mess-up and in the candidates right and
in the candidates by the way on that
subject of momentum for just a moment it
was really the last round of the Tata
Steel chess tournament now when you know
Fabiana sits down and plays against
great grandmaster like Duda yeah you
think this is going to be a wonderful
fight and dude as in there with a chance
but the momentum was so overwhelming you
know you just looked at it I said
do that before moving on I mean if he
draws this game it's gonna be a miracle
and it really happened that that fab
ease form was overwhelming is momentum
and it was unstoppable
he wasn't stopped a lot of the games it
just didn't matter what position he got
right I mean that King March he did
against B to go I remember watching it
live I was like wow that's a great win I
mean he's gonna take some time but you
know he's Fabi I've seen him calculate
he's gonna find it and then I don't know
what I was doing it then two minutes
later you just achieved it won't be too
good we have a call from Rhode Island
please give us your name on your
question why this is Tom hi Tom
hi yes early on drew and Maurice thanks
for the great commentary thank you I
wanted to ask when they're analyzing for
variations of an attack and one results
in winning the exchange like getting a
rook for a night in the pond or look for
Bishop you often move on to two other
variations with the understanding that
it's worse for the defending player and
without the zero emphasizing peace
activity over points do you always see a
plan for the attacking player to make
use of that point differential because
sometimes it looks like the attacking
players rook is boxed in or if the
defending player retains both bishops
and there's open diagonals it looks good
okay you're asking a kind of a general
question while giving is a specific
example you're attacking yes and you've
got like two three really good choices
and one wins in exchange it's a good
idea to take it really depends on a few
factors an exchange is kind of a
borderline material level where you can
have compensation for an exchange of
full exchange and still being in the
game very if you got an exchange in a
pond or a pond it's almost equal right
at this point I'm not even really
considering this a great win of material
right I'm thinking I need more from my
attack if there's nothing better than my
attack is fizzling
and certainly I'm going to catch it but
if it's an attack for a
a knight on a pond for a rook I don't
feel satisfied I don't feel like I could
really accomplish much especially if my
position is now in fear because as you
mentioned the Roku's box then or
something like that nowadays you know we
consider two pawns to be a winning
advantage a full exchange to be a
winning advantage piece to be a winning
advantage in exchange for a pawn it's
not enough
right I mean normally you will have
something that needs to be proved for
the positions to be considered winning a
lot of end games in which you have an
extra exchange for a pawn or winning but
that's because the rook is so far
superior but in middle games you don't
really feel the power of the rook so
when you mention the office of your
activity of the pieces it's very common
that even grandmasters will skew going
for something as material and avoiding
the material being and jump right in
Maurice I'm not a materialism so I'm
looking to destroy you I don't want your
measly exchange right and you get a pawn
on top of it like a knight and a
mourning is your knight better suck
because just having the rook not enough
but I'll say all these questions you're
asking and great questions but the
bottom line is it all depends on the
situation it all depends on the
situation on the board one shifting of a
pawn on the board upon on a six versus a
pawn on a seven could completely change
the evaluation of whether or not you do
that we saw these end games just
yesterday we saw the Indian between
Geary and neppo exact and the difference
between a pawn and f2 and f3 is the
difference we know win and injure
whether or not you go for this ending or
whether or not you keep you stay and
play so everything is always so specific
that what you do is you increase your
chest skills you increase your ability
to assess situations and when they come
up you can look and say this exchange is
good that one is garbage I know where to
stay and everything is always going to
be specific I feel like it can never
answer a question like that one because
you don't have generalized formulas and
chess the better you get the better you
are able to assess all these situations
and Korchnoi himself the late great
Viktor Korchnoi I know was a great
friend of yours yes sir he
the great players are the ones who can
find those exceptions mm-hmm
you know you're in situations this is
not one of those I'm going to do
something different that we don't look
for generalized rules we look to be very
clear in any given situation to find out
what we should do one of the things that
I am seeing in the top play the play of
the top players today is that they are
really I mean they're avoiding the
material they really really are they are
really playing for the activity and just
keeping you under pressure
it doesn't like they don't catch in they
don't have is Wayne how cashing in no
let's figure it out he's just being
given a check on b2 which it might be
helpful because essentially this move
King f3 is saying like check me again
and allow me to go up the board go up
the board and harass the night and try
to utilize the pawn be a little bit more
clever I really don't like taking on g3
with the rook ok I was wondering what
the continuation was after no I don't
like rugby 3 at all I'm sorry but let's
go Knight d2 nothing David to try to
figure out how you okay I'm gonna do and
now I take g3 but with my night right
now I'm thinkin new gets played today
you can't cross I'll excuse me cross on
the default because two wins the rook on
d8 I thought I was just being so smart
and going King to d3 to c3 yeah sorry
let me let me bring clue and everybody
here I had overlooked that the knight on
f1 defends the rook on d2 and I just
scared and lost the rook an easy
oversight by the way Kramnik himself
overlooked a main lead one I was there
against the computer d that started G
Fritz dropped made in one when it's
night was on f8 and it played Queen 87
mate and gromek overlooked because he
said Knights don't belong on f8 i then
controlled backwards I made the wrong
move
start with kini - yeah so this one looks
because this is the position that I was
trying to achieve a moment ago and then
I was thinking that okay my beep on you
you're right you you got your G
three-pound I'm sorry but like why
couldn't I win the exchange again hold
on did I do it again no king d3 rook the
rook Ditu is definitely fine for black
oh boy well then that means I have to do
really ugly not I'm not happy at all
I wanted activity but this is a three
result game King III on the board
Knight of 92 check your priority because
he's really down on time right oh by the
way yes let's mention that for mates for
for not a real time pressure he has 58
moves made he needs to make two more for
15 extra minutes okay everyone check on
the board as well
quick king of three pretty quickly and
hope for a repetition he did the same
yesterday right I did the exact same
thing against England right absolutely
he didn't go for the bishop captures age
4 immediately yeah against England e
repeated with his rook yeah I remember
in the middle so you trying to get to
the time control so he'll do that again
here and we'll see we're expecting to
see King F 3 it is moved 58
I guess plenty of time to these oh he's
got two moves yes yes sorry I just kind
of got off-track there there's also be
three check as well suddenly - I was
like you mean after I play King of three
yeah I'm thinking okay this is the
current game position right Knight f1
check as we've been mentioning you can't
go to the D file you don't want to walk
into a room D to check so King F 3 on
the board and now on each remember that
night was on b6 yep like I mean Francie
my goodness have a choice right after it
and that f1 Czech [ __ ] does he have
another move
am I missing something
or is my g3 Jack right right no King f3
books boss yeah box but he has no time
so play quickly play quickly and figure
it out right I'm gonna tell you right
now it's easy to say as the the the
outsider yeah and one just is one of
those games where external coaching is
not allowed right right so accepting the
olympians if you withdraw offer and
think because should I take the draw you
talk to your team captain but it's one
of those games where external coaching
is not allowed and in right now if you
are lying how's coach
you would say all right listen things
aren't going very well clear your brain
you may not win this game calm yourself
down accept that and just play the board
play the board give yourself some
chances you know you could breathe and
say you know what you're right you're
right I didn't mess this up there's a
long tournament ahead let me but if
you're by yourself you're sitting there
you're lying on your you don't have that
you're going are still wanna win no no
I'm gonna make it happen and you don't
clear your brain like you're sitting in
the chair and we all know there's a
tournament place you're in the chair
you're gonna insist on what was past and
keeping that and you don't just let go
and flow in the moment it's easy to say
from the outside and if you had a
culture say listen look into my eyes I'm
telling you what's going on to be in the
real moment now is one of the hardest
things for competitors to do and this is
a moment he's in he's got to start
saying maybe I don't win but don't
blunder something don't don't be stupid
because you're trying to win so much
that you blender something and blow the
game completely well this is like the
carrying the baggage right from your
winning out of the oh yeah yeah and now
you know you're winning yeah and then it
gets worse and worse and worse and now
you've you thrown it away but you're
still carrying the baggage of the fact
that you were winning out of the opening
and you're still determined to win
instead of having a clear head visor
laid off that's where I see guys like
fabbi
and magnets are so good there's another
day treat yeah they keep calm they
they're very objective but by the way
don't overstate that pretty objective
they're pretty objective remember
Fabiano Caruana version of Cobie in
yours championship the ways upstairs is
saying we've seen panic even among the
elite elite it happens in this this is a
very important competitive moment and
exactly you just don't want to fritter
it away
well the 392 plate and wang hao only
house two minutes to make one move but
what move is all he needs right ok let's
take a look I'm gonna play King each I
have to and I said I'm gonna go 94 I
also don't seem and I'm gonna play King
d1 again I'm not gonna walk into that
skier or I'll think on g3 and yep ok now
if I go king c1 I'll go rook before
exactly and I'm gonna go King I want to
try to chase I want you to win as many
pawns that makes you happy right and
your guys night if I I'm gonna take all
of them ok and let's go
ok in here I have to go to be one I
don't see much of a choice ok right and
avoid man no now once you sacrifice h4
which is done you were done yeah hard
for me to believe that why it's gonna
end ever ever end up worse but there
will be situations where gets 100 result
games all the game I'm gonna win that
for at some point even if you win a rook
you're not guaranteeing anything that is
true ok but I don't see any I mean
otherwise it's on the board 294
otherwise that's it's all green spot and
you know by the way I have to say if I'm
in Wang Hao shoes I'm saying this is an
opportune
of a lifetime for me yeah I mean you
know I've got to try to win this game it
if I draw like we say you know second
bestest well nice nice price fine thank
you I mean seize the moment see you see
and that's the mincer that's the mindset
you're back in that mindset again right
but don't screw up again right don't
screw up the game and I am surprised you
said that because he's at +1
he needs plus 3 and he's gonna have 12
more games to do it right it doesn't
have to be this game you're gonna have
some you're gonna win so we're gonna
lose some you're gonna draw some you go
to draw a lot if that's what happens you
happen not to get it don't make the
round number 2 the bellwether of the
whole tournament no make sure you don't
screw up because if you screw up you're
in big trouble you don't have to over
press what's gonna be the next time
control 15 minutes right it's right yeah
15 minutes for the whole rest of the
game with your 30 second increment
you're gonna be hard for you to play
perfect chess for the future so I think
the right mindset is don't be scared you
get 3 king of 392 Zadro that's a beauty
play king of three that's three folds so
he actually is repeating the position
and I think he's accepted that this is
not a knot he's not willing to go for
the danger he's got a long tournament
ahead don't blow it now I believe that
is a three time repetition am i
miscounting Maurice I don't think so I
think 90 I think just a second that is a
draw draw a green one Colin and you're
scared grid escape Wow absolutely Wow
The Great Escape indeed well how I was
going to be kicking himself for this one
nope what a mess by the Chinese player
definitely a winning position and this
couple of clumsy moves rook T to Bishop
c6 letting this night go escape yep Oh
once you saw the night start dancing
like that and there's only you're
dropping material and all that that's
when you you know I think I think
actually he might be kicking he will be
kicking himself
oh don't get me wrong but at the same
time I'm I'm impressed by his
objectivity he did not this he did not
say I'm just
win at all costs yeah he said the right
thing to do here competitively is accept
my flaws I did not do a good job
let me not blow it let me not just screw
this game up and somehow manage to lose
you know he did the right thing for the
moment now that said I'd rather see him
play so we can see him maybe screw up
but but I think he did something
extraordinarily professional in this
moment hard to accept that you blew it
and say I was wrong I played that well
we all guys for wait wait I Fabiana
corona maxine bashar lagrangian
pneumonia she am now one how all at one
point and a half plus one for all of the
grease truck sitting does the loan
surprisingly loan % i was about to say
with one point qlx and conan each gear
with minus one or half a point and the
sole well at the basement its tingly ran
he's just not started well at all but we
have more fireworks for you tomorrow
join us of course as we have round three
pairings Dingley red vs Fabiano corona
just before the tournament this one's
that matchup but right now it's a leader
against somebody with zero points let's
see what Dingling brings it does have
the white pieces so if you'll at least
have that comfort and each year will
playing is Maxine Bashar allograph who
comes from a victory both players
certainly happy with the result one
because didn't lose and the other one
just crushed his opponent fishing
against war how and Alex and code
against yon and there for me at you
another Russian matchup and he received
all of the leaders play with the black
pieces tomorrow how ironic that is all
of them for leaders and everybody with
the black pieces
nice Maurice final thoughts of this very
exciting game to absolutely a dynamic
day indeed four players tie for first
that's pretty good +1
happy Fabiano Caruana of course he would
a blasting crushing day he had and MVL
also showing some dominance of course
Tingler and we'll have to get it
together we expect to see something from
him
will he be able to pull himself together
and be able to fight back
oddish here he's got to be filming us
big sigh of relief
let me draw a few games for a while he's
thinking and then maybe win a couple and
get myself back on track
this has been a very exciting tornament
indeed everything we could possibly hope
for and I'm SPECT expecting more to
continue tomorrow Thank You Maurice well
thank you yeah sir hey what's the
pleasure on the second round join us
tomorrow third round of course same time
same place
exciting games yes don't miss it we'll
be here thank you everyone for joining
us
[Music]
[Music]